gee Barrette teaches us Docker
containers and kubernetes fundamentals
course for beginners ghee is a developer
and trainer with more than 25 years of
experience he is a Microsoft MVP
frequent conference speaker and was the
leader of the montreal.net user group
for more than 23 years all this is to
say he is the perfect person to teach
you about Docker and kubernetes
[Music]
welcome to this Docker containers and
kubernetes fundamentals training course
my name is gibaret and I'll be your host
in your Learning Journey Into The
Amazing World of containers
I'm a full-time trainer with a developer
background and I'm based in Montreal
Canada and that's where my strange
accent comes from
I'm certified on kubernetes and also on
terraform Azure AWS and Google Cloud
I'm very honored to be a Microsoft MVP
in the Azure expertise and a
digitalocean navigator
you can reach me via the contact page
and on Twitter
what should you expect from this course
you will not become an expert just by
taking this course this is an
entry-level course that will provide you
with a strong containers and kubernetes
Foundation
and you'll gain enough knowledge to make
sound decision at work or in your
projects
throughout this course you will find
lots of Amazon activities to practice
what you've learned
you will use Docker and kubernetes
locally on your PC or Mac so there's no
requirement to have an account with a
cloud provider
are there any prerequisites for this
course not really if you're a developer
a devops specialist an ID Pro or even a
technical manager that's totally fine no
previous Docker or kubernetes knowledge
is required
we will cover a lot of ground
you will learn about containers Docker
and D Docker registry
you learn about the kubernetes objects
like pods workloads and services
that's a lot of material and the goal
here is to get you from zero knowledge
to a kubernetes ninja
well at least provide you with enough
knowledge to Aspire being a kubernetes
ninja
I want to say a big thank you for
learning Docker and kubernetes using
this course
if you like the course you can help me
by making a small donation this is the
link to my buy me a coffee page
you can of course buy one of my other
courses where you'll learn to run
containers on different Cloud providers
services and use a managed kubernetes
cluster in the cloud
and finally I wish you all the best in
your Learning Journey
[Music]
let's see how to set up your laptop or
PC for this course
you need a laptop PC or Mac with either
Windows 10 Mac OS or Linux
if you have a Mac with an apple silicon
most tools should run perfectly
I will use Visual Studio code with the
docker extension to help build create
and run containers
vs code is a free IDE that runs on
Windows Mac and Linux
on Windows and Mac you'll need Docker
desktop with kubernetes enabled
on Linux refer to the documentation on
how to install Docker and kubernetes on
your distro
you'll need a Docker of account
and a few easy to install tools
refer to the setup instructions located
below this video
the lab files are located in a git repo
on GitHub
simply open this URL in a browser
click on the code button
if you have git installed on your
machine you can type git clone with the
link displayed here
and if you don't have git simply click
on the download zip button to download
the code as a zip file
[Music]
let's talk about the microservices
concepts
if we head to Wikipedia and take a look
at the definition that we find over
there it says that it's a variant of the
service oriented architecture or SOA a
structural style slash architecture
and that it arranges in application as a
collection of loosely coupled services
so instead of a large monolithic system
we have multiple smaller pieces
in a microservices architecture services
are fine-grained meaning that each of
them have their own responsibilities
and the protocol use are lightweight
like an API exposed over HTTP or grpc
for example
if we look at the monolithic
architecture
these systems were usually built as one
single unit
an IDE would group multiple projects and
we would compile the whole thing as one
single unit
they were also deployed as a single unit
so we would need to copy everything all
the files on on a server
and if we had to scale the system we had
to spin a new VM and copy deploy the
whole system on that VM and same for a
third and a Ford server
an example of such a monolithic
architecture is a treaty application
even though the system was clearly
separated into layers
it was all tightly coupled from the web
project we had to make a reference to
the business layer project and the whole
system would run in the same address
space
with macro Services we break our big
system into smaller parts each with its
own responsibility
so let's say we have a class that deals
with identity in our business layer we
can extract that code and place it in
its own microservice
we can then scale each of these smaller
pieces independently from each other
there's no strong bound since we expose
functionality through an API
they can be written by smaller teams and
each can use their own programming
languages like go PHP C sharp
and domain-specific data can be stored
in separate databases
so the way we would deploy a monolithic
system is by deploying everything on a
server all the dlls files needed to run
the system
we had to scale the deploy everything on
more servers
now let's compare that to microservices
well
microservices are deployed independently
each can scale independently also
need to scale back one service
no problem
so if you have an existing monolithic
system how can you transform it into a
microservices architecture
well you need to break it into small
units like the code that dealt with the
identity in the in our business layer
Martin Fowler author of the patterns of
Enterprise application architecture book
documented the way to achieve such a
transformation using the Strangler
pattern
let's say our identity code is here in
the Legacy system
we can place a facade to Route the calls
to it migrate the code
and have the facade route the calls to
the new macro service at some point
as we go we will end up with less code
in our Legacy system
and when democracy and it's done we can
get rid of the facade
this pattern is very useful and you can
learn more about it using the link in
this slide
and this concludes this lecture on the
Marco Services Concepts
[Music]
let's talk about Marco Services
anti-pattern because it's a thought
Rosie I know it's kind of strange to
talk about what can go wrong right away
but I think it's very important
first of all
it's not some kind of magic pixie dust
that you can sprinkle on top of a
zigzing system and boom you get a
beautiful Marco Services architect
system
it takes efforts and maturity to achieve
this
from one monolithic system you'll end up
with a bunch of smaller pieces and that
can add extra complexity
a change to a microservice can have a
domino effect and take your system down
and what about securing all of these
microservices
it's also essential to use or introduce
new processes in the organization
like devops Ci CD and testing
but be careful and don't try to
implement everything at the same time
it's a recipe for disaster
take it step by step and make sure you
have metrics in place to validate each
of these steps
and this concludes this lecture on
microservices antibatterns
[Music]
let's talk about the microservices
benefits and drawbacks
since each microservice runs in its own
address space
there are less chances that if one of
them goes down it takes the whole system
down with it
a microservice runs on open source
Technologies so there's less Fender
lock-in
since they are smaller in most case they
are easier to understand
and that makes them faster to deploy
and also easier to scale
like we saw in the anti-pattern section
there are some drawbacks
complexity is added over mother's
existence to resolve to her complexity
issues
so make sure your team is well trained
and has made some proof of concept and
make sure to start small adding one
piece at a time
testing might appear simpler since there
are less functionality in a microservice
to test
but make sure to test the whole system
deployment may appear simpler but one
update can impact many Marco services
and have a terrible domino effect
ready to manage multiple databases
calls between macro services will go
through apis and this will add a bit of
latency to all calls so make sure you
test for that
this key transition server will appear
you'll make a call and it will fail or
but try again 50 milliseconds later and
it will work
so make sure to implement some retry
strategies in your code or by using a
service mesh
instead of one big point of failure
you'll end up with multiple ones can
your system survive if one microservice
goes down
and what about security
are you okay for all these microservices
can see and talk to each other
so yes complexity is introduced for
solving complexity issues
and this concludes this lecture on the
macro Services benefits and drawbacks
thank you
[Music]
let's Now understand what is cloud
native
you may have heard the term Cloud native
before
but what it is exactly
it's a way to architect and build
complex systems taking advantage of
modern development practices and the use
of cloud infrastructure
if we head to the cloud native
Foundation website and look at the
definition
we see that it's quite a long one
so let's break it into smaller parts
Cloud native uses containers service
meshes microservices immutable
infrastructure and declarative apis
we'll cover containers service meshes
and macro services and the concept of
immutability in this course
but not how to build apis
immutable infrastructure means that we
usually never update something but we
replace it with a newer version
Loosely coupled systems mean that the
functionalities are exposed through apis
observable with the use of metrics
creation and updates are automated
and instead of making changes once every
six months we deploy eye impact changes
on a freaking basis
and finally we use a series of Open
Source projects to run our system
when the cncf says to use open source
projects they are not kidding
this cncf landscape graph shows a ton of
Open Source projects that you can use
but don't worry you don't have to use
them all
the challenge really is to identify
which one to use in the context of what
you want and try to achieve
and this concludes this lecture on cloud
native
head to the cncf website for more info
[Music]
let's go deeper in the cloud native
Concepts
Cloud native is about Speed and Agility
the user wants new features right away
without any downtime
and the business wants faster release of
feature to stay competitive
a cloud native application architecture
starts with clean code
using domain-driven design techniques
Markle services
and kubernetes
this course is all about microservices
and kubernetes
feel free to explore the concepts of
clean code and DDD on your own
with Cloud native we need to change
mentalities
infrastructure becomes immutable and
disposable
it is provision in minutes and Destroy
as fast
it is never updated but it's replaced
with newer versions
traditionally we would care about our
virtual machines
we would patch the OS update the apps
with containers we create newer version
with the software updates
destroyed the previous running ones
and replace them with the newer ones
so the containers that you'll run will
be more like cattle than pet
of course this Cloud native thing is a
lot easier when starting a new project a
blank page or a green field
however it's still possible with Legacy
projects
I really like the cloud native
Foundation trail map because it breaks
the journey to Cloud native into smaller
measurable objectives
you can set your own performance
indicator to measure each steps to
ensure a smooth Journey
so let's take a look at the first steps
your team must first learn how to
cantonerize your application
the developers and the IT Pros must know
how to deploy and monitor containers
you need to automate deployment through
the use of continuous integration and
continuous delivery techniques and tools
you need to use an orchestrator like
kubernetes
and maybe deploy your application using
L charts
then you need to add observability so
you can understand what's happening in
your kubernetes clusters and be reactive
use tools like service meshes to provide
more functionalities inside your cluster
Implement security through policies
and wow these were just the first six
steps Now understand that you don't have
to implement all of this and especially
not at the same time
I really like this trail map because it
breaks the journey into smaller steps
that the management can understand and
measure
and this concludes this lecture on the
cloud native Concepts
[Music]
let's take a look at the cncf website
the website is located at cncf.io
and from there you can take a look at
the various projects maintained by the
cncf
information about on how to get
certified
Community Information like the
conferences that the cncf organized each
year
so let's go back to the projects menu
and you'll notice that projects are
categorized in three categories sandbox
incubating and graduated let's click
here on this the second menu here
and let's scroll down to the bottom and
here you get the information about the
meaning of these three categories and
basically that's their maturity level
sandbox projects are mostly newer
projects uh well graduated projects our
projects set conservatives Enterprises
are more likely to use
so let's take a look at the graduated
ones we found here kubernetes
Helm Jagger so let's click on kubernetes
and basically that will show you the the
project website
let's take a look at the incubating ones
here we find Linker D grpc let's click
on grpc you can get more information
about the grpc
all right
let's go back to this menu remember the
trail map that I mentioned in the
previous lecture well here it is cloud
native trail map
here's the nice diagram you can get more
information you can get send that to
friends colleagues
and here's a link to the landscape
diagram
here it is it's super huge
Let's uh let's click here on kubernetes
and here we get very interesting
information
well you get the repository where the
project is uh is stored you get the
number of stars and the activity number
of commits here
you get you get the website address
and also the Twitter handle here
so you should follow the Twitter feed of
the project that you're using so let's
close this one
let's click here on hell
again
website
uh repository number of stars activity
and the Twitter handle
and this concludes this look at the cncf
website
thank you
let's now talk about the containers
Concepts
containers containers containers
they are everywhere but what are they
exactly
a container is a unit of deployment
it contains everything needed for the
code to run
so the compile code the runtime system
libraries and this is system tools
you take a container push it on a server
and it should run of course it can have
some external dependencies like a
database or a cache but the code
deployed in it should run as is
so why use containers
because it is faster to deploy something
small than something big like a complete
monolithic system
uh they use fewer resources they are
smaller
and since they are smarter you can fit
more on the same server
when using cicd techniques they are a
lot faster to deploy
you can run them anywhere
and they are isolated from each other
meaning that if one fails
it will not take the whole system down
with it
so what exactly is virtualize
let's compare virtual machines with
containers
a VM runs on some kind of Hardware where
an OS is installed
the OS hypervisor will let you create a
virtual machine
where you will install in OS
so basically DVM virtualized the
hardware
and what's happening when a VM starts
well you see the BIOS coming up and then
the OS boots up
and what about the size of that VM let's
say we have a Windows Server VM
it can take 12 gigabytes of RAM and 500
gigabytes of hard drive space
and how long does it take to boot
well depending on multiple factors
something like 5 to 10 minutes
now let's compare that to containers
we still have the hardware and the OS of
course
there's a container runtime installed uh
in the OS
and containers images are run in memory
now compared to a VM a container does
not have to boot
because it will use the host OS kernel
this means that container starts in
seconds because they don't have to boot
they also use a lot less memory and hard
drive space since there's no OS
a small container can take a hundred
megabyte of hard drive space and run in
64 or 100
megabyte of RAM
so VM and containers
virtual machine have a larger footprint
they are slower to boot
ideal for long running tasks
container are lightweight they're quick
to start they don't have to boot they're
portable
and they're ideal for short-lived tests
because they you can spin one super fast
so are containers replacing virtual
machines
our virtual machines obsolete
absolutely no containers are just
another tool in your toolbox
and you need to find the right use case
for them and also for VMS
if you're old enough you must remember
what the telephone booth is if not well
before cell phones we used to make phone
calls in these spoons by dropping a dime
or a quarter anyways
using a telephone boot analogy you can
pack more containers on the same server
than what's possible with virtual
machines
containers are made of layers
you start with the base OS
add customizations
and add your applications
let's take a deeper look at this
screenshot
the docker pull command retrieves and
download a container image
as you can see each layer is downloaded
individually
notice that each has a unique ID
and that for the first ones Docker says
that they already exist why is so
Docker uses a local cache to store the
container's images and if a layer
already exists it will not be downloaded
again
the benefit is that if you pull version
2 of an image Docker will only download
the layers not present in its cache
one of the goal when creating container
images is to create them with the
smallest number of layers possible
later on we'll see techniques on how to
achieve that
now can you write on these layers
well no except for the top one because
it is read right
the lower ones are read only
another concept is the container
registry
it's a centralized repository where you
deploy the container images you create
think Gita but for containers
Docker as one called Docker up that
provides public and private repositories
and all major Cloud providers have
container registry services
the last container concept is the
orchestrator
an orchestrator allows us to manage
scale monitor the containers that we run
on our servers
you can install your own
or use a managed cluster offered by one
of the cloud providers like AWS Azure
Google Cloud
we will come back to the orchestra
Concepts after we have a better
knowledge of containers
and this concludes this lecture on the
containers Concepts
[Music]
let's Now understand what is docker
so what is stalker that may seem like a
simple question but there's more to it
there's Docker the company
and Docker the platform
document thinks the Mobi project an open
source container runtime that follows
the specs from the open container
initiative
doctors sold its Docker Enterprise
division late 2019 to a company called
mirantis
so if you want to buy Enterprise support
or get certified with docker you have to
go through morentis
Docker provides a container runtime
that runs on Mac windows and Linux
a command line tool to create and manage
a containers
a Docker file format for building
containers
and interestingly Windows lets you
create both windows and Linux containers
foreign
if for some reason Docker doesn't seem
to work on your machine try restarting
it by using the restart menu from the
system icon on Windows
or by clicking on the debug icon in
Docker desktop on Mac and windows and
clicking on restart
Docker desktop is very stable but I had
some issues when my laptop was coming
back from hibernation but that was a
long time ago and I haven't had issues
for a while
and this concludes this lecture on
docker
[Music]
the easiest way to run Docker on your
machine is by running Docker desktop
it's a free download available on
docker.com so you click here on get
started
and you download the version for your OS
so Windows Mac Linux here
now if you're running Windows uh check
the version of Windows that you're
running
if you're running Windows 10 version
2004 or a later version
you can run what what's called windows
subsystem for Linux version 2. so wsl2
basically it allow you to run a Linux
distribution right into your Windows
installation so Docker desktop can run
its container by installing a virtual
machine inside hyper-v or if you have
wsl2 install it will it will install
that virtual machine
inside the Linux distribution and
everything will be a lot faster so
that's the preferred way so just to
prove a point here I'm going to launch
my hyper-v
miniature
and as you can see I'm not running any
virtual machine so my Docker desktop
installation uses wsl2
you'll find a link to this installation
guide in the modules notes
okay so let's take a look at the docker
desktop I'm running Windows as you can
see I can see my Docker desktop system
tray icon here so for Mac User it'll be
at the top of the screen of course I can
right click on it and let's select
dashboard
all right so here I can see a list of
um containers that are currently running
I can stop them restart them delete them
I can see a list of uh images that are
installed on my machine here we'll come
back to that later on there's a gear
icon here that's the setting icon and in
the general section here
you can see that
wsl2 is enabled so that's why Docker
desktop doesn't use a Now preview
virtual machine it uses the wsl2 to run
the VM
and there's the kubernetes menu here if
I select it I can see that
kubernetes is enabled so when you check
that Docker desktop will download
additional containers to run kubernetes
right onto Docker desktop here so very
useful
there's a bug icon here which is the
troubleshoot icon here so
if at some point you're issuing Docker
commands and the don't work or
something's wrong uh running Docker
Docker commands
you can click here on the restart button
here
you can see my name here it means that
I'm currently logged and if I right
click down on the system play icon
you can see that I'm currently logged in
and I have the option to to sign out so
what uh username and password did I use
to to log in
when you downloaded the uh the docker
desktop you could have created a Docker
account or a Docker Hub account so
that's the same username and password so
if you go to
up.ducker.com and you logged in well
that's the same account that is used
here in Dr desktop
thank you
[Music]
let's take a look at your first Docker
CLI commands
now throughout this course I will
introduce you to various commands
I will list them in what I call a cheat
sheet list like what you find on the
slide
I will briefly explain what the commands
are for
and that will be followed by a concrete
and Zone demonstration
so when you install Docker desktop on on
your Mac or PC
it also installed the docker CLI tool
our first command is Docker info
this will display some information about
the docker installation on your machine
Docker version will display its version
and Docker login will log you into a
Docker registry
by default this login command will log
you into Docker Hub the registry from
docker
and this concludes this lecture on the
docker CLI
[Music]
alright we need to open a new terminal
window into Visual Studio code so let's
select a terminal new terminal or you
can use the shortcut Ctrl shift back
tick key
all right this will open a terminal
window and let's take a look at the
commands that we will run they're really
basic
it's just for testing that our Docker
installation is working correctly so
let's type Docker info
this will give me some information about
my current installation what's happening
I have 47 containers three stuff 44
running 25 images and so on and so on so
information that that is quite useful
for debugging purposes I can see that
the virtual machine running that running
Docker desktop is running as to CPU it
has two gigabytes of memory allocated
all right sounds good let's uh type now
Docker version
and this will uh give me some
information about the version number of
different parts of Docker desktop
so again useful for debugging purposes
these are not commands that you will run
on a day-to-day basis but they're quite
useful for troubleshooting the last
command is Docker login so I'm just
going to type Docker login without any
username password see what's happening
and well the command says that I am
login successfully why is so
well if I right click here on my Docker
desktop I can see that I'm already
logged in so that's why I didn't have to
input or type any username password I
was already logged in
[Music]
let's now see how to run containers
the docker pull command lets you
download an image from a registry
Docker run will execute an image in
memory as a container
if the image is not present in the
docker local cache it will be downloaded
automatically
using run with the Dash D flag will run
the container in the background
giving you your comment prompt or
terminal back
the start command will run a container
in the stopped state
Docker PS will list all the containers
currently running
and add the dash a flag to also lists
all the stopped ones
Docker stop will stop a container
running but the container will still be
in memory
we will see how to remove them from
memory in a few minutes
Dr kill will well kill a container that
might be stuck in memory
you usually don't use this comment but
it's useful to know
Docker image and spec will give you some
information about an image very useful
for debugging purposes
so you may notice that we have two
parameters here
one is called image name and the second
one container name so what's the
difference
the image name is the name of the image
as you find it in the container registry
and the container name is the name of
the running container
so you run an image using its name and
then interact with it using the running
instance name
the Run come in as an optional flag call
dash dash name that lets you specify
your name
if you don't specify one Docker will
Auto generate one for you
you can set limits on the memory and the
CPU that the container can use when
using the Run command
so how do you run a container
using the docker run command you specify
the image name as found in the container
registry
you specify a name for the running
instance
and with the published flag you map a
port from your local OS to the port that
the container is listening to
you can list the running containers
using Docker PS
notice how we stop the container by
using the running name and not by using
the image name
then we remove it from memory using the
remove or RM command
containers are not black boxes you can
attach a shell to your terminal and run
commands that will execute right inside
the running container
by using the dash it switch and the name
of the program you want to run
a Windows container well you can run
Powershell
using the docker container exact command
you can attach to a running container
here's a screenshot showing the docker
run command
and notice the terminal problem changing
when attached to a container
so how do we clean up things
the remove command lets you remove a
container from memory
but first it must be in the stop state
for the command to work
here's the remove command getting a list
of the stopped container and removing
them all
the images that you pull will be cached
locally
you can get a list of these images using
the docker images command
use the remove image or RMI command to
delete an image from your machine
after a while you may end up with a
bunch of images
to do some spring cleanup I use the
system prune command
this will delete all the image currently
not in use so be careful using this
command
and this concludes this lecture on the
docker CLI
[Music]
let's now run our first container we'll
run an engine X web server so something
pretty basic that'll be perfect for this
this lab all right let's open a terminal
so terminal new terminal or Ctrl shift
back tick
perfect
so we'll run disk command so let's take
a look at the command first
so I'm going to run a Docker run
and let's go at the end of the command
this will be the image that will run so
an nginx image
we'll give it a name
so the name will be web server that will
be the name of the running instance
will map local All Sport
8082d or that the container is listening
to so port 80.
n d 4G decimal so we can get our Command
Prompt or terminal prompt back so let's
run this
ha something interesting is happening
unable to find image nginx latest and
you see that the docker as pull all the
different layers locally here
so now if I issue a Docker PS
it will list the containers that are
currently running so I have uh three
containers running so the kubernetes
dashboard and the metric server here so
don't uh look at these let's focus on
this one so this is the containers it is
that we just launched the nginx image
here
it started 30 seconds ago
we can see that the port 8080 local
levels is mapped to the port 80 here and
the name is web server
so let's launch a web browser and let's
type localhost 8080
the container is actually running
fantastic all right
so we can get a list of the images
installed on your machine here by using
Docker images so I have a bunch I may
have a lot more than you but let's focus
on the last one here uh nginx the tag is
latest image ID and this is the uh the
size
all right fantastic let's try to connect
to uh to it so we'll issue a Docker
container exact
we'll give it the the name so the
running instance and the program we want
to run
so look at the The Prompt now
root at some some ID so the ID is the
actual container ID so I'm logged in as
root on that container so now I can
issue some some commands so let's do in
the last
let's thy fell less been to see what's
in there so different commands so I'm
connected to to that running container
that's pretty uh pretty cool so I can
issue commands look at the logs if any
and do some troubleshooting so this is
super useful
for debugging purposes uh we'll use that
a lot in the various steps that we'll do
together
all right let's get out of there by
typing exit
all right you can just clear my screen
here
so our container is running how do we
stop it we use the docker stop command
but
look at the the parameter that we use
the name of the container that we use we
use the running instance name not the
name of the image so that's pretty
important here
Docker stop web server
all right but the container is still in
memory if I do a doctor PS
it's not listed anymore as you're
running container but if if I type
darker es Dash a
ha for all I can see that my my
container is still in memory here
so I need to remove it from uh from
memory
so we'll use the docker RM and the name
of the running instance so RM for remove
and now the container is no longer
in memory awesome
now
the container is still well the image
that was used to create the container is
still on my machine
so if I type darker images
you see it's still it's still here
so that takes 133 megabyte of this space
if I want to get rid of that I use the
RMI so remove image command and the name
this time of the image not the name of
the running instance because none are
running right now
and you see all the layers
have been deleted
[Music]
let's now see how we can build
containers
Docker build that you create an image
using a Docker file
if you run the command in the same
folder where the docker file is located
simply use a DOT as the file name
if the file is located in a different
folder specify the location using the F
flag
the tag command let you assign a name to
an image
this tagging has two parts
a name and a tag
the tag is usually used to specify the
version number
so what is a Docker file
well it's a text file listing the steps
to build an image
here's the simplest Docker file I can
imagine
two lines
the from command specified the base
image
when building new images you always
start from something already existing in
this case an image with the nginx web
server using the Alpine version
and then the copy command copies
everything from the current folder to a
folder inside the container
using the build command we create a new
image specifying the docker file
remember to use the dot when the file is
located in the same folder
here's another one this time a little
bit more complex
it is used to create an image running a
node.js app
let's take a look at it
the from command specify the base image
using the Run command we run the package
manager inside the container to install
node.js
next we copy all the local files into a
folder named SRC inside the container
we use the Run command to do an npm
install
we then had some metadata in this case
we tell the container to listen on port
8080
and finally we tell the container what
to run when starting
so as you see this Docker file contains
the stats needed to run our node.js app
we saw what tagging was a moment ago
let's explore this again
using the docker tag command we name an
image using a name and optionally a tag
if you don't specify a repository name
it will default to Docker Hub later on
we'll see how to push images to
different repositories and we'll have to
specify the Ripple's Journey name when
tagging our images
and this concludes this lecture on how
to create Docker images
[Music]
let's see how can Visual Studio code
help us build and run containers
so what is visual studio code and why
talk about this tool in this course
well it's a text and code editor
it's free and open source
it runs on Windows Mac and Linux
and you can download it for free using
this link
so you will work a lot with text files
creating Docker files and later on
Docker compose and yaml files
a tool like vs code will help you
because you can install plugins that
will make your life easier
using a different text editor no problem
in vs code you can install plugins by
clicking on the extension icon in the
left menu
then you search for Docker and install
the extension from Microsoft
the extension lets you add Docker files
to your projects using the command
palette
open it using the view menu or type Ctrl
shift p
type Docker add and select add Docker
files to workspace
the extension will ask you a few
questions
and we'll create the docker files for
you
vs code has a built-in terminal where
you can type commands
or you can run commands using the
command palette
here's another example when running a
container
and when using the command palette
there's no magic there the extension
will simply issue a command in the
terminal
but sometimes it's a great way to learn
creating Docker files is okay but what I
like the most is the UI provided by the
extension helping me manage my container
so if you click on the docker icon
you can see the images installed on your
computer
and you can even see the containers
currently running
right click on an image to manage it
same thing for the containers currently
running very very very useful
and this concludes this lecture on vs
code
thank you
let's now use Visual Studio code to
containerize a node.js express
application
so I already installed the docker
extension in Visual Studio code but
let's take a look at it so if I click
here on extensions
and let's search for docker
here it is
that's the one from Microsoft almost 6
million install at the time of recording
so that's the one
all right so let's go back to our files
so I have my node.js application here if
I click here on package.json
[Music]
the name of my application is my Express
app so that'll be important in a few
seconds
all right so let's first add the docker
file to our project so we'll use the
tooling provided by the extension to do
that
we'll go to the view menu command
palette or you can use the shortcut Ctrl
shift p
right and we'll type Docker add and
there are two options here Docker files
or Docker compose files so we haven't
looked at the docker compost file so
let's select the first one Docker files
the extension hack is asking us about
the application platform so it's a
node.js application but it can generate
Docker files for net python Java C plus
plus go and Ruby apps so let's select
node.js
all right and next next it's asking us
where is the package.js file so here it
is it set the root of my application so
I'll select this one
the port that the application is uh
listening to 3000 perfect
and do I need the optional Docker
compost file no not at this time
all right so the extension quickly added
a the docker file and also the docker
ignore file and also a folder for vs
code so let's take a look at the docker
ignore basically it's a list of files
not to deploy in our container
and the docker file has been created for
me to use a node base image it copies
everything into the Container the image
and expose port a portrait 3000 perfect
so let's now build this image
so we'll go back to the command palette
view command palette Ctrl shift p and
this time we'll search for Docker build
all right here it is Docker images build
image
all right so I just issue uh the command
and look look at what's happening
the extension is not a black box uh
issuing some crazy or strange uh
commands in the background it's just
issuing a
a Docker Bill command here
and remember a few seconds ago I
mentioned that the name of the
application in the package.json file is
is important well that's the name of our
uh of our application here so the
extension use it to generate the name
for my image
all right
it's just a Docker Bill command nothing
fancy but using this extension is a
great way to learn about some uh some
commands that you may want to use at a
later time from the terminal prompt
okay terminal will be reused by test
press any key to close it let's press
any key all right
the image has been built let's run it
now so view command palette
okay Doctor run
so we'll use the first one
and uh there's a list of my images
and here is my Express app
perfect
run that
select image that's the latest the tag
latest perfect
and look at what's happening Docker run
sport 3000 to the port that the
container listening to so nothing fancy
here is uh it's a comments that you can
type yourself but uh the extension to
that are for you so if I
start my browser local ocean I go to
Port 3000
there it is
so that worked
perfect
let's now close this
let's now use the UI provided by the
extension so in the left menu let's
click on the docker icon here
and from there you have a list of the
running containers the images and the
different Registries that you connected
to all right so here's our Express hat
my Express apply it is and it's running
name the instance name is called magical
underscore Direct
uh why is so well when we issued a
Docker run command using the command
palette
the extension didn't provide a name so
uh one was generated automatically by by
docker
so from there I can view the logs attach
shell
inspect open in a browser so if I select
that
there it is that's my app listening on
Port 3000
uh I can stop it restart it remove it so
let's uh let's remove it here
so are you sure you want to remove
container yes
it's not in memory anymore it's not
running anymore
but if I look at the list of the images
that I have here it is my Express app so
I can right click on it
and I have a few options I can run it
inspect it pull push tag and even delete
it so let's let's run run it
okay and you see at the top my Express
app
and look at the name gifted underscore
El beckyan
because if you look if you uh inspect
the docker command that was issued
by the extension there's no name
provided
so Docker generated one for us
all right so let's close this
we can stop or remove it from memory
and if we no longer need the image we
can just remove it here
are you sure you want to remove the
image blah blah blah
okay let's remove it
and it's gone so
what's happening in the background is
that the extension is simply issuing a
Docker remove image RMI to to remove the
image from from this so nothing nothing
really fancy the extension it's not a
black box that is issuing some strange
commands it's just regular and Docker
commands but I really like the the UI
provided here
and so instead of uh typing uh okay
let's uh let's try this let's
um
let's clear this and let's type Docker
images
here's a list of my all my images but
here I have a nice UI listing all the
the same images here so sometimes it's
it's easier having a little UI to help
you accomplish some tasks other times
it's easier issuing the commands from
the terminal or the command prompt so
it's up to you you can use the UI or The
Terminal
thank you
[Music]
let's talk about data persistence
containers are ephemers and stateless
so you don't usually store data in them
of course you can write data in a
container but if you destroy one or if
it crashes any data stored in it will be
lost
so it's okay to write some log files or
scrap data that you don't want to keep
as long as you understand that you will
lose these files at some point in time
to purchase data you need to store it
outside the container in what we call a
volume
a value Maps an external folder or even
a cloud storage service to a local
folder inside your container
so your app sees a volume just like any
regular folder
the OS in this diagram represent the
server or the virtual machine where the
container is running
as you can see a local folder is mapped
to the VM file system so they are stored
in a volume where survive a container
restart or crash
there's still a chance that we can lose
the data if the VM crashes so later on
we'll see how we can use some type of
external storage provided by the cloud
provider
but first thing first in the next
lecture you'll see how to create a
volume that maps to a VM file system
and this concludes this structure on
data persistence
[Music]
um
let's see how to create volumes
here's a cheat sheet listing the docker
commands for managing volumes
Docker create volume will create a new
volume
LS will list all the volumes
volume and spec will get you information
about a volume
remove will delete a volume destroying
all the files storing it
and volume prune will delete all the
volumes currently not mounted or not in
use
so be super careful careful using this
command
alright
you first need to create a volume using
the docker volume create command
then when you run a container you need
to use the V switch or to volume a
parameter
specifying the volume name a column and
the name of a local folder that folder
will be a logical folder in your code
so your code will see just like any
regular folder
if you use the inspect command you'll
see The Logical folder location in DVM
instead of using a volume you can
specify a local folder
this is great for testing purposes let's
say you started developing your service
and that you want to test on your Dev
machine
if your code can read and write some
files correctly you can use this kind of
mapping but don't use that in production
using the inspect command you can see
the local folder path
and this concludes this lecture on
volumes
[Music]
a software system data outside of a
running container
so to do that we'll use a value
so I'll open a terminal
and we'll use the docker volume create
and the name of the volume so this will
create a volume
perfect let's Now list the volumes on my
machine
so there's a few here the first four
were created earlier
this is the volume that we just created
now let's run a ninja next image
and let's attach a or Mappy a local
folder to that volume so we'll use
Docker run Dash D for detach we'll name
our instance fault test with the Dash D
for volume we'll use the volume name
that we created earlier and map that to
a folder called ATP on our nginx image
all right
to that
okay excellent so that worked now let's
connect to our running instance so
Docker exec Dash it the name of the
instance and it will run bash here
perfect
let's first do an LS to see if we see
the app folder there it is so that's
that folder is mapped to the volume so
anything that we store or write in that
folder will be written externally
outside of the container so that will
persist
all right
uh just for fun instead of
doing a cat Let's uh install Nano inside
the running instance so I'll do first in
apt-get update
remember this is uh this is running
inside the the container and we'll
install Nano app get the install Nano
which is a small editor perfect
LCD into the app folder
in open Nano so Nano and we'll create a
file called text test.txt
hello
volume
[Music]
all right and we'll use Ctrl o to write
to to disk Ctrl o enter and control X to
exit Nano perfect
if I do an LS here
I should see my file there it is
test.txt so let's exit the running
instance and what we'll do will stop the
running instance and we'll remove it
from memory
stop it
here
and we will remove it from memory with
our m
okay so now the container or the
instance is gone if we would have stored
some data inside that container it would
it would be lost at this point but we
use a volume so the data was stored
externally so let's try to create a
second instance
same thing using the same volume and
let's exec to it
perfect let's
see what is in the app folder here is
our file so let's do cat
test.txt just to prove hello volume
that work
let's exit here
this proved that by using a volume your
data persists a container restart or
crash here
the data is still there
until I remove the volume so if I issue
a Docker volume removed and the name of
the the volume you see doesn't work why
the error says that the volume is in
news
interesting so I need to stop
any container instance that is that is
running
and remove it from memory before
deleting or removing
a volume let's try uh again
term Docker volume RM for remove by
volume
and this time it worked
now another thing I want to show you let
me create it again
perfect and let's switch to the docker
UI here if I click Docker here
there's a section
that list of the different volumes here
so my vowel is listed here
so here I can inspect I cannot look at
the files but I can I can manage it so I
can click here on remove that will
delete the volume
are you sure yes
[Music]
let's now see the yaml concepts
yaml stands for yaml ain't markup
language
it's a way to serialize data so that
it's readable by human beings
it's the file format used by Docker
compose and kubernetes
here's the sample yaml file
for a key value pair you specify the key
a column
data space and a value
don't forget the space it's mandatory
here are some nested values
you specify child values using two space
indentation
and quotes are not needed for string
values
here's a list
again the child elements are indented
with two spaces
and there's a space after the dash
this is what we call the block style
there's also a flow style that looks
like Json
so you may be tempted to use it if
you're familiar with Jason but don't I
never saw any sample or any
documentation using this flow Style
since it's easy to forget a space
and you can spend quite some time
figuring out why your yaml file doesn't
work
you can use tools like this linter
available on yamlin.com
it will parse your yaml and flag any
errors very useful
and this concludes this lecture on the
yaml concepts
[Music]
let's now take a look at the docker
compose Concepts
let's say that your app is composed of
multiple containers
you run the front-end container using a
Docker run command
Docker run again for the backend
container
and again for the redis cache container
so you end up issuing multiple Docker
run commands to run your app
would it be nice if you could deploy
your app using one single command
well that's the docker compost go
to Define and run multi-containers
application using a single yaml file
there's a compost plugin that extends
the docker CLI and let you run those
Docker compose files
these specifications are available here
if you look at Docker compose before you
may have seen that sometimes the
commands are using an iPhone so Docker
Dash compose
and sometimes they do not
why is this
at the dockercon conference in 2022
Docker announced the general
availability of couples version 2. okay
this means that there was a V1 before
and the V1 command line tool was
installed separately from the docker CLI
it was built using python so you needed
to have python installed to run compost
V1
and the syntax was Docker Dash compose
couples V2 is a drop in replacement
meaning that all the V1 commands are
working as expected
it's installed as the docker CLI plugin
automatically by Docker desktop
to use it you type Docker space compose
no hyphen needed here
it's written in go so no need to have
python installed to run the command
in summary it's simply a faster version
of the docker compose tool shipped as a
Docker plugin instead of a python
application
here's a Docker compose file
there are three containers defined in it
web API 1 web API 2 and API Gateway
the name that you use here defined the
network or host name for that container
the code running inside your container
can use these hostname to communicate
between each container
for each of them you specify the image
to run you set the internal and external
Port the container will listen on note
that the API version is now optional so
it's okay to skip it
you may ask yourself should I use darker
compose or not
Docker compose is perfect for small
workloads that don't require a full
orchestrator like kubernetes
it's perfect When developing and testing
locally before deploying to kubernetes
Some Cloud providers offer services that
support Docker compose like app service
on Azure and ECS on AWS
and of course you can simply use a
virtual machine or a VPS virtual private
server with the digitalocean or linued
and this concludes this lecture on the
docker compost Concepts
thank you
LaSalle used Docker compose
here's a cheat sheet listing some of the
docker compose commands
Docker composed build lets you build the
containers as defined in your Docker
compose yaml file
if the file is located in another folder
you can use the optional Dash F per
meter and specify the files location
start we'll start all the containers as
defined in your yaml file
step will stop them but they'll remain
in memory
up we'll do a build followed by a start
this is super Endy
use the Dash D parameter to run the
command in the background and take back
your terminal prompt
PS will list what's running
remove our RM we'll remove the
containers currently from memory
down we'll do a stop followed by a
remove again this is super ND
logs will display the logs for a
container
and you can open a session inside a
container by running Docker compose exec
the container name and the program to
run
the docker compose file is located
inside a folder and if you run Docker
compose up
this will launch your application
if you try to run a Docker compose up a
second time from the same folder nothing
will happen because the application is
currently running
if you want to run a second instance of
your application it was impossible with
Docker compose V1
but with V2 you can use a project name
to launch a second instance of your
application from the same folder
here's the cheat sheet for some of the
new commands
Docker compose dash dash project Dash
name followed by a project name
this will run a then sense of the
application as a project
the shortcut is much shorter to type
Dash p instead of that Dash project Dash
name
you can list the project currently
running by using compose LS
CP will allow you to copy files from the
containers so this is super ND to
retrieve let's say log files
and you can copy files to The Container
so from your machine your desktop or
laptop to The Container by using Docker
compose CP The Source pad the container
ID and the destination path
here's an example imagine that the
docker compost file is located in the
same folder where you run these commands
you simply use the up command to build
and run the containers and to take them
down simply use the down command
and this concludes the structure on
Docker compose
[Music]
in this lab we will deploy a Docker
compose application
let's take a look at our Docker
compose.yaml file
we have one section called services and
under that section we Define two
Services the first one is called Web
Dash Fe F4 front end it's a python
application and instead of using an
image from Docker up will be building
that image using the build parameter
the dot means that the docker file is at
the same level as the docker compose
file so here it is
it's a simple python application just
one file app.pi and requirement.txt that
we're copying on that base image
it will be listening on Port 5000 and
this is our second service it's the
redis cache and this time we'll be using
an image from Docker up
all right let's open eight terminal
and let's build the image using Docker
compose build
perfect my image was build now I can
launch the application using Docker
compose up and Dash D for detach now I
could have skipped the build step
because up does a build first and then a
start so it's super ND
so let's use Docker couples up
and my application is up and running I
can test it if I go to local OS 5000
you visited me one time and do a few
refreshes five time perfect
okay I can list the running containers
using Docker compose PS
I can also use Docker PS since it will
list the docker container currently
running
and I can look at the logs for my
front-end service using Docker compose
logs Dash F and the name of the service
and if I
move that a little bit
and it F5 a few times you see
new entries are logged perfect
that works
let's do a Ctrl C to terminate the log
streaming
and we'll use Docker compose LS to list
the currently running projects
I have one project running it's called
l09-04 Docker compose well basically
when I use Docker compost up I didn't
specify a project name
so Docker compose use the folder name as
the project name
now let's try to create a second
instance of our application if we use
Docker compose up Dash D again
well Docker compose tell me that the
application is running so it will not
start a new version we can try to deploy
our second version using a project name
so Docker compose Dash p for project
name
we'll name it test up Dash D
let's see what will happen
starting oops we have an error here hmm
bind for local OS 5000 failed Port is
already allocated of course are my local
old sport 5000 is in use right now
so what I need to do
I need to change that Port here the
localhost port I'll use 5001 save the
file
and use the same command Docker compose
Dash B project name test up Dash D
and this time it worked awesome
let's open our browser
and let's go to Port 5001
yes that worked
a few refreshes 10 times let's go back
to Port 5000 the first instance
15 times
all right
so let's do a Docker compose LS again
to list our projects now we have two
projects the first one that we deploy
without specifying a project name and
the second one with the project name
test
let's delete our for instance by using
Docker compose down
so I didn't specify a project name
Docker compose use the folder name as
the project name now if I do the docker
composer list I should have only one
project running yes it's test now I can
delete that one using Docker compost
specifying the project name and down
let's list the projects again Docker
composer less
nothing running PS
listening the containers nothing and why
not try Docker PS
nothing in memory
[Music]
in this lab we will deploy a Docker
compose sample application
that is composed of three services a web
front-end build with react
nodejs backend and the Maria DB database
let's take a look at our Docker compose
file
this is a more complex than what we saw
so far so let's try to break it into
smaller pieces
here we have the definition of our tree
services if we start from the left we
have the back-end service
top right the database DB
and the front end now if you look at the
DB service you can see that we're
referencing an image that will pull from
Docker hub
and the other two Services we're using
the build parameter
this means that we will build these two
images
looking at the backend service we can
see that we specify build and context
contacts with the value of backend
backend is actually a subfolder where
the docker file is located
next we're defining two networks public
and private
we can see that our front-end service is
using the public network
the backend service is using public and
private
and the database service the DB service
use only the private Network
front end being in the public network
cannot communicate directly with the DB
service
but backend being in both public and
private can communicate with both DB and
front-end services
we're defining also two named volumes
back in dash modules and DB Dash data
and we can see highlighted in yellow
that our DB service is using DB data and
our backend service is using back-end
modules
highlighted in yellow we also see that
we're using other volumes these volumes
are scoped at the service level and are
not shared between services
to create an instance of our Docker
composed application we simply use
Docker couples app and to bring it down
Docker compose down
in Visual Studio code let's take a look
at the docker compose file so it's
called compose.yaml
here we have our services section
Network section where we Define two
networks the name volumes back-end
modules and DB data and secrets that we
haven't seen yet where we're defining
one key value pair so the key is DB
password and we get the secret from a
file the file is located in the folder
called DB and it gets the value from a
file called password.txt if we open the
DB folder here's the file with the value
the secret
and that will be injected when we run
Docker compose up
okay let's go back to the services
section and here we have our backend DB
and front-end Services let's take a look
at backend
we're using the build a directive and we
are setting the context to backend it
points to this folder called backend
here and the docker file is located
inside that backend folder with the
application
same thing with the front-end service
build context front-end and we're
getting the docker file and the
application from the front-end folder
and what about the DB service well we're
using an image that will pull from
Docker hub
okay let's build our two images
we'll open a terminal
and run Docker compose build
our images were billed perfect now let's
run the application by using Docker
compose up Dash D
ER perfect the application is this thing
on Port 3000 so let's open a browser
and type local OS 3000
is our react application it's working
awesome
we can list the containers that are
currently running by using Docker
compose PS
we should have three backend DB front
end awesome
let's take a look at the logs from the
back-end service Docker compose logs
Dash F backend
and these are the logs for our backend
service awesome
we can type Ctrl C to stop the log
streaming
and we can take our application down by
using Docker compose down
this will stop and remove the containers
from memory
do we have something else in memory we
should not
perfect and even if I type doctor PS
there's nothing however the volumes are
still there when you do a doctor compose
down it will remove the containers from
memory but will not remove the volumes
so if I open the docker desktop
application and I click on volumes here
I can see that I have a few well three
volumes that were created a few minutes
ago
so I need to delete them manually I can
select them right here and click on
delete or I can do the same thing by
clicking on the docker icon in vs code
locating the volumes here
and delete them
find it easier to do that in Docker
desktop because we see when the volumes
were created so I'm pretty sure that
these three are the ones that I need to
delete I'll click on the delete button
and confirm
thank you
[Music]
let's take a look at some of the compose
file features
it's a good practice to set limits on
the resources that your container will
use
in this example I light it in yellow we
tell Docker to start the container with
a quarter of a CPU and 20 megabytes of
RAM
the green section is the limits that we
are allowing in this case half of a CPU
and 150 megabytes of RAM
to set an environment variable that will
be injected in the running instance
simply set the key value pair in the
environment section
those values can be overridden at the
common line using the dash e per meter
you can reference an environment
variable using the daughter curly
bracket syntax
this way you can set the variable on
your machine or server and use it
directly in the compose file
you can place the values in a file that
you will name dot EnV located in the
same folder as the compose file the
compost command will automatically read
the values from that file
by default all containers specify in a
compose file will see each other using
their service names here we have two
Services web and DB
the code running in the web service can
communicate with the second one using DB
as the hostname and vice versa
the web container is visible from
outside of the docker network using the
port number configured in the left
portion of the ports value
web is listening inside the docker
Network on Port 80. DB can reach web on
Port 80.
finally DB only exposes one port number
that's the internal port
web can reach DB using Port 5432
but DB is not visible from outside the
docker Network
if you have a compose application with
multiple containers you can restrict who
sees who by configuring networks in this
example we're defining two Networks
front end and back end
proxy can see app because both are part
of the front-end Network
however proxy does not cdb because it's
not part of the backend Network
when using multiple containers you may
want to start some of them first and
wait until they are running before
starting the other ones a typical use
case is a database that you want to run
before sorting the main application
doing so is easy using the depends on
parameter where you simply specify what
is the service name that the service is
dependent on in this example app depends
on DB so compost will first start DB and
when DB is running compose will then
start app
you can declare volumes in the volumes
section
these are called named volumes and they
can be used by all these services that
you are declaring in the compose file
to use a volume from a service map it to
a local folder using the volume name
colon and the virtual path inside the
container
optionally you can make the mapping
read-only by appending colon Ro to the
mapping
you can also create a mapping without
using a named volume
this mapping can't be shared across
services
it's also a good practice to set a
restart policy
let's say that you deploy your couple's
app in a VM
and at some point you need to install
some OS batches and you need to restart
or reboot the server
what will happen to your compost app
well if you don't specify a restart
policy
the one by default is no meaning that
compose will not restart the containers
if they were shut down by reboot
you can set the policy to always this
way compose restarts the containers
until their removal
on failure resource a container if the
exact code indicates an error
and lastly unless stop does a restart
unless you stop or remove the containers
and this concludes this look at some of
the docker compose features
[Music]
let's now talk about container
registries
so what is the container registry it's a
central repository for container images
you build an image locally
then you push and store the binary the
different layers
2D Repository
they can be private or public
the default one is Docker hub
Microsoft AWS and Google each offer
container Registries as service
the benefit of using a repository from
your cloud provider is that the images
are located near your app so no apps
over the internet to retrieve the images
so let's say we want to retrieve an
image from Docker up
we issue a Docker pull command and
Docker downloads the images layers and
store them in its local cache
and this concludes this lecture on
container registries
[Music]
let's see how to push and pull images to
Docker up
make sure you are logged in with your
Docker user account to be sure simply
type Docker login
without a username and password
Docker will tell you that you're already
logged in if not enter your Docker
username and password
you need to tag an image with the
repository name by default it's your
username
if you have created some organization in
Docker hub
prefix it to the name of the image
in this example I want to push this
image to my Kates Academy organization
then use the push command and don't
forget to specify the organization name
it's part of the image name
to retrieve the image we use the pull
command with the image full name
on Docker up public images are available
for download to anyone
if you don't want to share them you need
to create a private Repository
later on we will create one using our
cloud provider
and this concludes this lecture on
Docker up
[Music]
let's now push our first image to Docker
hub
first thing first let's make sure that
we can log in into Docker Hub so if you
head to
up.docker.com make sure you can log in
also if I right click here on my Docker
desktop icon I can see that I'm logged
in
perfect
we will containerize a node.js Express
application so we'll first add the
docker file
we'll use the tooling so view command
palette
if you can type Docker add and Docker
files to workspace
this is a node.js application
the package.json file is located at the
real so that's the correct one
it's listening on power 3000 and we
don't want Docker compose files
perfect
now we need to build the image so let me
open a terminal
perfect and we need to issue a Docker
build command
with the Dash D for tag parameter
but notice here we need to prefix the uh
the name of the image with our registry
name
if I select this
I need to prefix that with
my name here the name of my registry
let me run that
the image was built successfully now I
need to use the push command to push
that image onto Docker Hub again I'll
select this
and let's replace the registry name with
mine
use your home
and see what's happening here Docker is
pushing each layer to my Docker app
account here
all right
no errors things went fine let's go back
here I'm gonna refresh this page
and here it is
here's my
um uh image here my Express image
so I can click on this
I can edit the
um
the information I can see that I have my
tag is V1
right I can get more information here I
can here click on public view so by
default the repositories on Docker Hub
are public anyone can download and view
and download your images this is the
view for someone who would look at my
image so with the pull command Docker
pull
let me go back here
I can see the tags
and so on and so on and if at some point
you want to delete this you go into the
settings tab here
you scroll down and you can delete that
repository here
all right let's go back
now let's try to pull that image to our
computer here
the first thing uh I will try to do is
remove it from my computer
let me
type this RMI so remove image
the image has gone completely so now
let's try to pull it from uh from Docker
uh
okay
Perfect Pull complete my image is is
back here
now
you see that I use the V1 tag here to to
tag my image with the with the version
number so let's try to build a version 2
of that image let me copy that
and again let's replace this part this
placeholder with my registry name
image has been built so let's now push
it
two Docker uh
same thing as we did before but this
time we're pushing version two
okay
let's go back here let's go back to my
Express or the general tab
look here I have V1 and V2
if I click here on tags
I can see when the image was was pushed
tags and people can download V1 or V2
if I want to remove my images
I use the RMI
command so remove image I'll remove V1
and also I remove V2
and on Docker up if I no longer need
this Repository
I click here settings scroll down a
little
bit
click on delete Repository
and I need to enter the name of my repo
just to make sure and click on delete
and now it's gone
[Music]
time to introduce kubernetes
so kubernetes or also known as Kates so
the letter K followed by the number
eight so eight letters
and then the number s
and it's pronounced Kate's so kubernetes
is a project that was created at Google
version one came in July 2015.
it was the third generation of container
scheduler from Google
previous projects were Borg and Omega
and Google donated the kubernetes to the
cncf so now the development is
supervised by the cncf
is currently the leading container
orchestration tool
it's designed as a Loosely coupled
collection of components for deploying
managing and scaling containers
it's vendor neutral so it's not attached
to a single company and it runs on all
Club providers
and there's a huge community ecosystem
around kubernetes
so what kubernetes can do
service Discovery load balancing
it can bridge to the cloud providers
storage services
can provide rollout rollbacks
capabilities
and can monitor the health of the
containers
can manage configuration and secrets
and the same API is available either in
a on-premising solution or in every
cloud provider
so what can't kubernetes do
it can deploy or build your code
and it does not provide application
Level services like databases service
buses caches
here's a quick look at the kubernetes
architecture
this diagram was taken from the
kubernetes documentation
we'll take a closer look at each
component but for now let's just say
that it's composed of a master node also
called the control plane so that's the
portion to the left
and the control plane runs the
kubernetes services and controllers
and you have the worker nodes these node
runs the containers that you'll deploy
in the cluster
so a container will run in a pod a pod
runs in a node and all the nodes form a
cluster
and this concludes this intro to
kubernetes
[Music]
let's see how you can run kubernetes
locally
so do you need to install a kubernetes
cluster in the cloud or ask your it
Department to install one in your
Enterprise so you can test locally
absolutely not there are many ways that
you can run kubernetes on a desktop or
laptop
Docker desktop lets you run kubernetes
macrocates from the makers of Ubuntu and
minicube also let you run kubernetes
altree requires that virtualization is
enabled
kind runs over Docker desktop and offer
extra functionalities
Docker desktop is limited to OneNote but
it's usually not a problem
Marco Cates kind and minicube can
emulate multiple worker nodes
on Windows Docker desktop lets you run
both Linux and windows containers
and you can't create and run Windows
containers on Mac and Linux
it runs on hyper-v or Windows subsystem
for Linux
so if you have Windows 10 version 2004
or later
it's the recommended way to run Docker
desktop
if fiber-v is enabled on your laptop or
desktop you can't run another hypervisor
at the same time
and mini Cube used by default virtual
box but it can also run on hyper-v
you can install Docker desktop on
Windows using App review and it will
create a virtual machine named Docker
desktop VM
when you take the enable kubernetes
checkbox in Docker desktop it will
download additional containers to run
kubernetes
using Windows 10 version 2004 or later
and if you have wsl2 installed you can
tick the use the wsl2 base engine and
Docker desktop will create its VM inside
the Linux distro you install on your
Windows machine
note that this is the recommended way to
run Docker desktop
on Mac Docker desktop use the hyperkit
lightweight hypervisor to run its VM
mini cube is another popular option
it does not require a Docker desktop it
runs on Linux Mac in Windows and it
requires an appervisor like a virtualbox
here we can see mini Cube running on a
Mac and its virtual machine in
virtualbox
if you need to install mini Cube on
Windows but don't want to install
virtualbox you can run minicube on
hyper-v
you need to create a network switch and
start minicube with some extra
parameters
kind stands for kubernetes in Docker
because it runs on top of Docker desktop
kind lets you emulate multiple control
planes and multiple worker nodes
this is useful if you need to test node
affinity
and this concludes the sector on how to
run kubernetes locally
[Music]
and this will be a super quick lab just
to validate that our kubernetes
installation is working locally
so here I'm on Windows and I'm using
Docker desktop and I installed
kubernetes with Docker desktop
in the system tray I can right click on
the docker desktop icon on a Mac you can
do that from the top of the the screen
and I will select dashboard
and from there we're going to click here
on the gear icon the settings icon
and I'm using wsl2 to run Docker desktop
so that's the recommended way
and here if I click on kubernetes
uh enable kubernetes is checks so
kubernetes is installed but is it
running correctly let's find out let me
go back here let's open a terminal
and let's run uh this command uh Cube
CTL cluster info
that should give us a little information
about what's running so kubernetes
Master it as in green yay it's working
so it's running at this address and Cube
DNS is running at this address
so by running qctl cluster info you get
some information about the kubernetes
installation and itself
[Music]
let's see how you can use the kubernetes
CLI
the kubernetes API server is a service
running on the master node
it exposes a rest API that is the only
point of communication for kubernetes
clusters
you define the desired state in yaml
files
and let's say you want to run a x number
of instances of a container in the
cluster
using the kubernetes CLI you then send
that desired state to the cluster via
the rest API
other applications like a web dashboard
can also communicate with the rest API
to display the cluster state
Cube CTL is the kubernetes CLI and it
runs on Mac Linux and windows
and you pick your choice of
pronunciation cue control Cube cuddle
Cube CDL doesn't matter
it communicates with the API server
and its connection information is stored
in a config file under the dot Cube
folder
let's now see what a context is
it's a group of access parameters that
let you connect to a kubernetes cluster
it contains the cluster name a user and
a namespace
the current context is the cluster that
kubernetes commands will run against
let's say that you can connect to three
clusters cluster a cluster B and cluster
C
when you set the default context to
Cluster B
then all the cube CTL commands that you
you will run will run against cluster B
here's a cheat sheet for context
commands
Cube CDL config current context will get
you the current context
get context will list all of them
Cube CL config use contacts and the
context name Will Set the current
contacts
and delete contacts with the context
name we'll delete the context from the
config file
there's a large ecosystem of free open
source kubernetes tools that you can use
Cube CTX is a good example
it's a shortcut for the Cube's DL config
use context command
you simply type Cube CTX followed by the
context name to quickly switch contacts
it runs on Windows Mac and Linux
very useful
and this concludes the structure on the
kubernetes CLI and the concept of
context
[Music]
a context contains connection formation
to a kubernetes cluster and you can have
one or more than one context set on your
machine it's super important to know how
to figure out in which context you're
currently in and how to change context
so first thing first let's figure out in
what context we're currently in I'm
going to use cubectl config current
context
and this will print the name of the
context we're currently in I'm currently
in the docker desktop contact means that
whenever I type Cube CTL commands it'll
be applied to that kubernetes cluster
all right I can have more than one
context configure on my machine or on
any machine or server to list them we
use Cube CTL config get Dash context
and here we can see that I have two
contacts set on my machine Docker
desktop which is the current context
because it has that star in the current
column and I have a second one called
demo then one is a cluster that I
created in the cloud
what if I want to change from Docker
desktop to demo
okay let's use cubectl config use Dash
context and the context name
demo
and now if
I print again the current context
there it is demo so whenever I'll be
typing Cube CTL command
DZ yaml files this command will be sent
to My Demo cluster somewhere in the
cloud
a cool tool is Cube CTX because it
allows you to well instead of using Cube
CDL config blah blah blah blah blah
basically it's a shortcut
if I simply type a cube CTX
that will print the context that I've
configured on my machine so demo is
green means that it's the current
context and I can quickly change context
using cubectx and the context name
Docker desktop you know a little bit
less keystroke to talk about anyway it's
a fun too
foreign
context let's say uh you you your
cluster has a long funky name and you
want to rename it to make uh more sense
you can use the cube CTL config rename
contacts all name new name so let's try
to rename our demo cluster here
demo let's say
it's on Azure so Azure demo
okay let's use the cube CTX to print the
contacts and there it is azure demo
where is that context information stored
it's stored locally on your machine so
I'm on Windows let's see where it is
it's on the C drive
users
your username
under dot Cube deduct Cube folder
and there it is config so if I right
click on it
and select opening with code
we can see that it's a yaml file
and it contains two entries here two
clusters
one is the Azure one and the second one
is the
Docker desktop one
and this is the different context that I
have that have so here is my Docker
desktop context
and here is my demo context
well the cluster name is still demo but
I renamed the context name to Azure Dash
demo
there it is
all right
let's go back here
and let's say that I've deleted my
cluster in the cloud I don't need it
anymore
I want to get rid of the contacts
information I can use cubectl config
delete contacts and the context name
so let's try this
Azure demo
deleted context Azure demo from the
config file so let's take a look here
and you see that now I have only one
contacts
and here's the current context
in this line here
but let take a look here at the Clusters
list
My Demo cluster is still there
right so it's not deleted automatically
what you can do is simply edit that
config file and remove the section no
longer needed
[Music]
let's talk about the declarative and the
imperative ways to create resources in
kubernetes
there are two ways that you can use when
you want to create resources in
kubernetes
the declarative way and the imperative
way
using the imperative way you use cubectl
to issue a series of command to create
resources in the cluster
this is great for learning testing and
troubleshooting
using the declarative way you define the
resources needed in yaml files and use
cubectl to send the content of these
file as the desired state to the cluster
so instead of a series of command
this is reproducible and you can even
store these yaml files in a source
control system
here we can see a series of command to
create resources that's the imperative
way
you can create a pod using the Run
command create a deployment or service
using the create command
using the declarative way
you would use a yaml file to define the
resource and then send the content of
that file to the cluster to create these
resources
so what's a yaml file
well it's a text file that contains
properties that Define the resource
it has some required properties like the
API version
the object kind that defines the type of
object you want to create
we'll take a look at these later on
you can use the cube CTL create command
to send the information to the
kubernetes cluster
we will take a deeper look at yaml files
in the future lectures but right now you
may be wondering
do you need to type all that yaml
manually
the answer of course is no
one way to get the correct syntax is to
copy one from the official kubernetes
documentation at kubernetes at IO slash
Docs
you then search for the object you want
to create
and click on the copy icon
another way is to use templates offered
with an editor like Visual Studio code
let's say you create a new yaml file
then you type control space and select
the template to generate the Manifest
that you can edit neat
you can also use the kubernetes CLI to
generate the ammo
add dash dash dry run equals client and
dash o for output
specifying the yaml to Output the yaml
to the console
you can even send the output to a file
using the greater than sign and a file
name
and this concludes this overview of the
imperative and declarative ways to
create resources in kubernetes
[Music]
let's deploy an nginx container using
both the imperative way and the
declarative way
using the imperative way uh we're gonna
type command called cubectl create I'm
going to create a deployment I'm going
to name our deployment my nginx1
I'm going to specify a parameter called
image where we will specify the image we
want to run
this will create a deployment
and we can Cube CTL get a list of the
deployments using Cube CTL get deploy
and there it is
now the second way is the declarative
way
instead of typing a command with all the
parameters at the common line we're
going to specify a yaml file where all
the configuration options are stored
cubectl create Dash f for file and the
name of the file
so let's run this
okay
it was created let's again type Cube CTL
get deploy
get both our deployments and we if we
take a look at the yaml file well it's a
yaml file the type deployment it has the
my nginx2 name it has a bunch of
parameters that will come back
to that a little bit later but basically
all the configuration parameters are
stored in that yaml file what's cool
with that concept is that it's you can
put these files quite easily in a source
control system
all right uh let's do a little bit of a
cleanup let's delete our deployment Cube
CTL delete deployment my nginx one
okay and I'm gonna use a the same
command but using a shortcut this time
Cube CTL delete
instead of deployment
and the name of our deployment
okay and if I type again Cube CTL get
deploy
there's no deployments currently my
namespace
[Music]
let's take a look at namespaces
so what is a namespace
it's a kubernetes resource that allow
you to group other resources
let's say you need to deploy your
application in multiple environments
like Dev test and prod
well you can create a namespace for each
of these environments
they are like logical folders in which
you group resources
kubernetes creates the default namespace
called well default
objects in one namespace can access
objects in different in a different one
the kubernetes internal DNS assigned
Network names to some resources
deleting a namespace will delete all
these child objects
this is super useful when doing tests
create a namespace in the morning
create resources under that namespace
during the day
and at the end of the day simply delete
that namespace
this command lists all the namespaces
existing in a cluster we'll take a look
at this command in more detail
okay
first you create a namespace this yaml
file Define a namespace called prod
then you use that namespace when you
create other resources
in the metadata section you set the
namespace key to the name of the
namespace you want this resource to be
created in
so namespace colon prod
you can assign Network policies and
limit the resources that you can create
in a namespace using the resource quota
object
here's a cheat sheet for the namespace
commands
so cubesatel get namespace list all the
namespaces
and if you don't want to type namespace
each time you can use a shortcut an S so
Cube CTL get an S is the same thing as
cubectl get namespace
you can set the current context to use a
namespace in the next commands that
you'll type by using cubectl config set
contacts
current with which will use the current
context and then the namespace is called
the name space that you want to use so
the next command that you'll type will
be under that namespace
cubectl create NS and the name of the
namespace so you create a namespace you
delete it using cubectl delete in s and
the namespace name
and you can also list all the pods or
the objects from another namespace so
Cube CTL get parts or any objects and
then you pass the flag dash dash all-
namespaces that will list all the
objects in all the different things
spaces
and this concludes this look at
namespaces
[Music]
let's see how to list and switch between
name spaces
you can get a list of the namespaces
using the cube CTL get namespaces
command
let me copy this
and these are the namespaces currently
created on my machine on my kubernetes
cluster so default the cube node Cube
public Cube system
I can also use the shortcut for
namespaces which is just few letters
which is a lot faster to type
and it will give you the exact same
result here
let me get a list of the pods running
Cube CTL get parts
no resources found in default namespace
that I'm currently my contacts is using
the namespace called default right and
there's no pods running in there
so what if I want to list the pods that
are in the cube system namespace
well I can use the same command qctl get
pass specifying the namespace switch and
specifying the name of the namespace
let me copy this
and there are many parts running here
here I can use also the the shortcut so
instead of typing dash dash namespace
equal I can just use the shortcut dash n
so only one dash here two dashes here
and the name of the namespace so let's
try this
and it works
perfect
now what if I want to change from the
default namespace or the namespace
called default to a namespace called
Cube system right and then apply all my
commands to so all the objects will be
created in that namespace well I can do
that by using the cube CDL config set
contacts dash dash current so here we're
modifying the context
and passing a switch called namespace
and the name of the namespace we want to
change
so we want to change instead of being
the default namespace all the time we
want to be in the cube system
okay and yeah let's see if uh if we run
Cube City I'll get passed if we would
get some pods of course because we're
currently in that Cube system namespace
okay now let's change back to the
default namespace
and let's get a list of the parts there
should be none
perfect
okay so this is how you uh you change
namespaces
perfect
of course we can create new namespaces
by using the cube CTL
uh create NS
for short for namespace and a namespace
name so hello
okay uh Cube
CTL get NS and my name space here was
created seven seconds ago
and I can delete a namespace using
cubectl delete NS and the namespace name
that and hello now
a bit of a warning here uh if you have
resources under that namespace these
resources the buzz the containers
whatever running will also be deleted so
use this command with caution
foreign
take a couple of seconds
okay let's get the name spaces and our
hello namespace is gone
[Music]
let's now look at the masternode
in nowadays the physical or virtual
machine
a group of nodes formed a cluster
the masternode is also called the
control plane
the kubernetes services and controller
are located on the control plane
they are also called The Master
components
and you usually don't run your
application containers on the masternode
the key value data Store where the state
of the cluster is stored
the API server is the only component
that communicates with its CD
let's start with the API server
it exposes a res interface and client
tools like the kubernetes CLI
communicates through that recipe
it saves the state in a CD
and all client interacts with the API
server never directly with the data
store
hcd is the data store for storing the
cluster state
it's not a database but a key Value
Store
is the single source of truths inside
kubernetes
the cube control manager is the
controller of controllers
its job is to run the other kubernetes
controllers
the cloud control manager job is to
interact with the cloud providers
a check if nodes were created or deleted
uh Route traffic create or delete load
balancers
and interact with the cloud providers
storage services
the cube scheduler watches for paths
that are not created yet
and selects a node for them to run on
it checks for various rules and then
assign the Pod creation to a node
finally you can install various add-ons
on the masternode
these add-ons provide additional
functionalities in your kubernetes
cluster
and this concludes this look at the
masternode
[Music]
let's take a look at the worker nodes
a node is a physical or visual machine
a group of nodes forms a cluster
there's a special node called the
masternode sometimes called the control
plane
where the kubernetes services are
installed
the nodes running the containers are
called the worker nodes
when a worker node is added to the
cluster
some kubernetes services are installed
automatically
the container runtime
the cubelet and the Q proxy
these are Services necessary to run pods
and they are managed by the master
components on the masternode
the cubelet manages the pod's life cycle
and ensure that the containers described
in the Pod specifications are running
and are healthy
the Q proxy is a network proxy that
manages Network rules on nodes
all Network traffic go through the cube
proxy
on each node you will find a container
runtime
kubernetes supports several container
runtimes that implements the kubernetes
container runtime interface
specification or CRI
one thing to note is that for kubernetes
version previous to 1.19
the Mobi container runtime was installed
and was receiving the container runtime
interface call through a shim
because it did not fully implemented the
specifications
this is not ideal as it added an extra
step
starting with kubernetes version 1.19
Mobi is no longer installed
oh wait a minute
Moby not installed that means that my
Docker containers will no longer run if
the docker container runtime is not
installed right
well the short answer is that your
Docker images will run as is nothing to
change its business as usual
what change is that what you can do
inside the cluster
since the docker runtime is no longer
installed
you no longer can access the docker
engine and issue Docker commands
directly inside a node
you'll have to use another tool called
crease CTL but again that's if you SSH
into a node and run commands directly on
that note
something that you don't do usually
alright
a node pool is a group of virtual
machines all with the same size
a cluster can have many node pools and
each node pool can host virtual Machines
of different sizes
let's say that we have two node pools in
our cluster the first one consists of VM
without gpus and the second one with
chip use
remember that Docker desktop is limited
to one node so basically you run the
master components and all the
application containers on the same node
and this concludes this look at the
worker nodes
[Music]
so let's get some information about our
nodes I'm going to run a cube CTL get
nodes
and since I'm running on Docker desktop
locally here
I have only one node name is Docker
desktop status is ready roll is master
here's the revision the version number
and it was installed 72 days ago all
right
I can get more information about the uh
the node uh since I only have one node I
can skip the node name per meter
and here's a bunch of information
the name the row some labels
creation date
um what else what else what else what
else uh the capacity to CPUs
uh number of PODS maximum number of
parts that I can run 110
the architecture the OS Linux
architecture AMD
the pods running and the CPU request CPU
the Miss memory so all useful
information when uh you need to
troubleshoot and debug
so that's pretty uh pretty interesting
now I'm using a locally Docker desktop
so I'm limited to one node Let's uh
switch should
to
um My Demo cluster
uh running in the cloud
so let's do the same thing Cube CTL get
notes
I have more notes now so I have a
cluster in in the cloud running three
nodes in a node tool so one two three
status ready agent and the version of
kubernetes that is running that's
interesting let me grab cubicity of the
scrap node and let's uh let's say use
this one
so I can get
the same information that I I was
getting earlier but this one is running
uh in the cloud
that's the name
role agent agent pool the different
labels
annotation
number CPUs memory
System Info it's running Ubuntu Linux
AMD 64.
uh what else will end the different
parts
that are running on this uh node
[Music]
let's take a look at parts
so what are pots
a pod is the smallest unit of work in
kubernetes
it encapsulate an application container
and represent a unit of deployment
paths can run one or more containers
inside a pod containers shame the same
IP address space and volumes
and they communicate with each other
using local laws that's inside the pod
s are ephemeral deploying a pod is in
atomic operation so it succeeds or not
if a pod crashes it is replaced by a
brand new one with a shiny new IP
address
you don't update the Pod that is
currently running
you create an updated version deleting
the first one and deploying the new one
you scale by adding more pods not more
containers inside a pod
I use this analogy in a previous lecture
pods are like cattle there are ephemeras
and you just replace them
a note can run many pods
and a part can run one or more
containers
if a pod runs multiple containers
there's usually one that is the main
worker where your application logic is
located
and the other ones are helper containers
that provide services to the main worker
we will come back to this concept in
another lecture
and this concludes this look at pods
[Music]
let's take a look at the Pod life cycle
we'll start with the creation life cycle
so when you issue a cube CTL create
command to deploy a pod in your cluster
the CLI sends the information to the API
server
and that information will be written
into a CD
the scheduler will wash for this type of
the information
look at the notes and find one where to
schedule the Pod and write that
information of course in a CD
the cubelet running on the Node will
watch for that information
and issue a command to create an
instance of the container inside a pod
and finally the status will be written
in a CD
one thing to notice is that each time an
operation is taking place inside the
cluster the state is written in its CD
so SCD is the single source of Truth in
the cluster
all right so let's take a look at the
deletion life cycle now
when you issue a cube City delete
command to delete a pod from your
cluster the CLI sends deformation of
course to the API server
that information will be written in SCD
and notice that the grace period of 30
seconds will be will be added
so the cubelet picks that information
and sends a terminate signal to the
container
if the container hangs it is killed
after the 32nd grace period
and finally the state is stored in a CD
The Path State will give you a high
level summary of Where the Pod is in its
life cycle
pending mean that the Pod is scheduled
for creation
but is not created yet
if you run out of resources in your
cluster kubernetes may not be able to
create new paths and if this happens
the parts will be in the pending state
running means that the part is currently
running
succeeded means that the code exited
without any errors
fail means that the code inside the the
Pod exited with the non-zero status
so some kind of error occurred
unknown means that kubernetes can
communicate with the pod
and finally crash loop back off oh I
love this in his state name so krashu
backup means that the Pod started then
crash kubernetes started it again and
then the Pod crashed again
so kubernetes say okay hold on I'm
stopping here
so we'll take a look uh in the official
letter of where to look for these states
and this concludes this look at the bud
life cycles
[Music]
let's see how to define and run pods
to define a pod the declarative way you
create a yaml file
specifying but as the kind
that's the type of resource you want to
create
you specify an image location in this
case the nginx image will be pulled from
Docker up that's the default container
registry
you set the port that the container will
listen on
you can add labels they are used to
identify describe and group related sets
of objects and resources
you can set environment variables
directly here
might not be the best idea to place
configuration values
in a later lecture we'll see how we can
externalize that by the use of a config
map object
you can even specify a command to run
when the container starts
if you have created a yaml file with
your pod definition
you use
cubectlcreate-f specifying the yaml file
location and name and this will create
your pod the declarative way
now if you don't have a yellow file and
you just want to run a pod the
imperative way you use qctl run you
specify a name for your running pod Dash
Dash image the image name
you can specify a program to run in this
case it's sh and dash C you can specify
a parameter that you want to pass to the
program
qctl get parts will list all the pods
that are currently running
Dash o wide will get you the same
formation but uh with a few columns more
cubicity Of The Scribe part and the Pod
name will show the pad information
you can use qctl get part with the Pod
name
Dash offer output
uh in yaml format and you can pipe that
to a file name so this is pretty cool
because
it will extract the Pod definition in
yaml and save it to a file
so if in case you lost that yaml file
that was used to create a pod well you
can recreate it quite easily
qctl exec Dash it specifying the Pod
name and the program to run will get you
inside that part in the interactive mode
you delete a pod using cubectl delete
Dash F specifying the yaml file or if
you don't have the yaml file simply use
cubectl delete pod and the path name
that will result in the same as the
previous command
and this concludes this look at how to
define and run pods
[Music]
in this lab we will run our first pods
we'll start by using the imperative way
we'll use the cube CTL run command
specifying the image that we want to run
in our case we want to run an nginx web
server
and we'll specify a name to the running
instance
my nginx
let's run this
pod my nginx created
let's get a list of the running pods by
using the cube CTL get pods command
I have one pod running my nginx ready
one of ones that is running it was
created 11 seconds ago
let's try to get more information by
adding the dash o y per meter
it's the same command but we'll get a
little bit more information like the IP
address of the Pod and the node where
the Pod is currently running
awesome
if you want more information
we'll use the cube CTL describe command
with the type of object
and the name of the running instance so
cubectl describe the type pod and the
name my nginx
all right tons of cool information here
the name of the object my internet the
namespace where it's running
uh the node where it's running start
time any labels annotation the IP
address information about the container
any volumes restarts that happen
and any volumes here
and at the end we get the list of events
that happened when the Pod was created
it was first scheduled
and then the image was pulled
and then the image was successfully
pulled
and created
and then started
the cube CDL describe command should be
the first thing you try when doing some
troubleshooting here you will likely
have some very useful information uh in
case a pod doesn't start maybe
the image is not available maybe the
image didn't start correctly also Cube
CDL describe command that's very very
useful
let's now delete our pod by using the
qctl delete the object type pod and the
name of the Running part
should get my command line back in a few
seconds
all right
let's now run a second pod this time a
busy box image
Cube CTL run the image busy box and the
name of the running instance my box but
we're adding extra parameters here Dash
it dash dash the program we want to run
this will open a session
inside our running pod
and look at the command prompt it's
changed to a pound sign this means that
now I can type commands that are running
inside the pod LS for listing the
folders and files I can run a
base64 command here I can encode a
string here and that happened inside the
running container inside the Pod pretty
cool
to stop the session simply type exit
and the this ends the session
okay let's do a little bit of cleanup
um in the busy box case uh it takes up
to 30 seconds to uh to delete so we have
two options here we can run the cube CTL
delete the object type and the running
AdSense and to get back our Command
Prompt right away we can use the dash
dash weight equal false per meter
or if we simply want to kill the Pod
brutally we use dash dash force and with
a grace period of zero seconds
let's run this
and this will kill the Pod brutally
all right
let's now create a pod the declarative
Way by using a yaml file
we have a yaml file here called
myhab.yamo
the kind is a pod we give it a name my
app dashboard
a few labels
the image we want to run
any limits here four degree sources in
CPU and memory
the port that the container is listening
to and some environment variable we're
defining an environment variable called
dbcon that will have a value of my
connection string here
awesome
let's use the qctl create Dash F4 file
and the name of our yaml file
pod my
app.pod created perfect let's run the
qcl get pods command to get a list of
our paths it's running
perfect we can also describe
our pod
again
same information that we saw earlier
right the default names the namespace
and here look we have our environment
variable
and the same events that we saw earlier
previously we used the cube CTL run
command with the dash it parameter to
open a session to our BusyBox container
now what is the Pod is currently running
well we can use the cube CTL exec
command with the same it
per meter here
we specify the Pod name and the program
we want to run
that will open a session to a part that
is currently running
okay let's output the
dbcon environment variable my connection
string awesome that worked
let's exit or stop our session
and this time we'll use the qctl delete
command specifying our yaml file to
delete our pod
[Music]
let's take a look at init containers
let's say that your app has a dependency
on something can be a database an API or
some config files
you want to initialize or validate that
these exist before launching the app
but you don't want to clutter your main
logic with this type of infrastructure
code
so what do you do
you can use an init container that lets
you initialize a pod before an
application container runs
let's say that for the app container to
run it requires a series of
configuration files
in the Pod definition you define a
container that will run first this is
the init container
upon completion kubernetes will start
the app container
this is a great pattern for applications
that have dependencies the init
container job can be as simple as
validating that a service or a database
is up and running
this keeps the infrastructure code out
of the main logic
init containers always run to completion
you can have more than one and each bus
complete successfully before the next
ones starts
if it fails the cubelet repeatedly
restarts it until it succeeds unless
it's restart policy is set to never
probe are not supported as ended
containers run to completion
in this bad definition file we have the
main application located in the
containers section in green
and the init containers in the init
container section in yellow
as you can see here we have two init
containers they both watch for services
to be up and running
so the first one we will run to
completion
then the second one
and finally kubernetes will start the
app container
and this concludes this look at init
containers
[Music]
in this lab we will use an init
container to modify the home page of an
nginx container
let's take a look at our yaml file
it's manifest for a pod
um we have two sections here containers
and any containers let's first take a
look at init containers
we will use a BusyBox image
and we'll run this command wget
and will it that
website right here and that website
it's the ohm of the first website the
home page of the first website is pretty
simple just a few lines of HTML
all right
and we will save that HTML into a file
called index.html into a volume called
work directory
and the nginx image
will map that value
and we'll serve that index.html page as
its default web page
so basically we're initializing our
nginx
container by using an init container
here
awesome
let's open a terminal
and let's deploy our application
Cube CTL apply Dash F the name of our
yellow file
let's wait till the nginx image is up
so if I do a doctor PS
yet my nginx container is a
oh let's uh open a session right into
that nginx container
and let's try to hit the default web
page curl localhost
and yep that worked we're serving the
default uh web page of the CERN website
here
pretty cool
let's type exit
and let's
do our cleanup
cubesatel delete and our yellow file
[Music]
let's now look at selectors
when defining kubernetes resources you
can use labels
these labels allow you to identify
describe and group related set of
objects or resources
they are simply key value pairs that you
define yourself
in this part definition we see two
labels
app
with the with a value of my app and type
with a value of front end
note that the app and type keys are not
something defined by kubernetes they are
defined by you for your application
okay but what does labels have to do
with selectors
well selectors use labels to filter or
select objects
here we see a selector in this pod
definition
the selector type is node selector
and the key value pair is this type
equals super fast
okay
but how does that work
here we have a path definition with the
node selector set to this type equals
super fast
we're telling kubernetes that we want to
run this bar on the Node that has a
label set to this type equals super fast
note a does have such label so
kubernetes will schedule the Pod
creation on that note
the simplest way to picture what
selectors do is by comparing them with a
SQL query
it would be something like select star
from nodes where this type equals super
fast
and this concludes this look at the
selectors concept
[Music]
in this lab we will test the selector
concept
we have two yaml files here the first
one
it contains the definition of a pod
we will run an nginx web server
listening on Port 80. and for the sector
concept what is enter is is this section
the label section so we have two labels
defined here
app set to my app
type set to front dash n
let's take a look at the second yaml
file that's the service of name my
service it's listening on Port 80 and
targeting or redirecting the traffic to
Port 80 that the Pod is listing on
and let's look at this section selector
app my app type front dash n so these
are the same labels that we Define
right here in our pod definition
all right
Let's test this concept
I'll open a terminal
and it will first deploy r
by using cubesatel apply Dash F and the
name of the yaml file
foreign let's now deploy
the service
Cube CDL apply Dash f myservice.yaml
all right how do we know that the
service is connected to the Pod how do
we know that the selection was
successfully made
to find that let's get the Pod IP
address by using qcdl get pod Dash o
wide
and let's look at the IP address here
10.1.9.31 all right
let's run this command cubectl get EP EB
is short for endpoint and here's the
name of our service my service so let's
run this
all right
you see D in the endpoints column
10.1.9.31 that's the same IP address
let's now try to port forward
to that service
okay we get an immediate result here and
let's uh go to localhost
port 8080 and that worked
perfect let's go back here to our
terminal and let's type Ctrl C to stop
the port forward
now let's try to break things a little
bit
we'll open the my app.yaml file and
let's change the one of the labels so uh
app will set it to my app to control s
let's save that file
and let's redeploy the file again the
Pod again
by using cubectl apply Dash F and the
name of the yaml file
all right
let's check the endpoint again
is it still working
huh
look at the endpoint colon none
and if we try to pour forward again
there's no immediate results so that
doesn't work
so disproved that both labels must match
here the selector here boat labels must
match the labels in in the Pod
definition
so that the selection can work
all right
let's type Ctrl C to stop this and let's
do our little cleanup by deleting the
service and then the pod
thank you
let's take a look at multi-container
pods
we sign a previous lecture that pass can
run one or more containers
that there's always a main worker and
that the other containers are providing
services to that main worker
like saving data to a database
and writing log files
there are scenarios while
multi-container Parts make sense and
they are well documented in a series of
patterns we will take a look at some of
them in the next few slides
with these sidecar pattern the helper
container provides extra functionalities
to the main worker
let's say that our app writes some log
files inside the pod
the sidecar can copy these log files to
some purchasing storage offered by the
cloud provider
this way the application code located
inside the main worker is not cluttered
with infrastructure code
that code is located in the helper
container
and if you move from one cloud provider
to another one well you simply replace
or update that L per code
this keeps your application code super
clean
our next pattern is the adapter let's
say that our main worker outputs some
complex monitoring information
that the monitoring surface of our cloud
provider cannot understand
the adapter role would be to connect to
the main worker
simplify the data for the monitoring
service
again the code specific to the cloud
provider service is located inside the
helper container
the Ambassador pattern is another type
of the men of the middle role let's say
that our application code needs to write
to some nosql database but the code has
no clue on how to do that
no problem you can send that data to the
Ambassador that in turn will write the
data to the nosql data store
the code specific to the data store
service is located inside the helper
container
if you're curious about these patterns I
suggest you get a copy of the design
distributed systems book the other is
Brennan Burns Brendan worked at the
Google where he co-created kubernetes
he now works at Microsoft
so how can you define multi-container
paths well if you remember the lecture
about yellow files
you see that the container sections is
actually a list
this means that you can Define multiple
containers
are added in yellow you see container
number one and in green container number
two and when you create a pod both
containers will be created at the same
time pretty cool
here's a quick cheat sheet for
multi-container parts
so after you created your yaml file you
simply use
cubectlcreate-f specifying the yaml file
name so same thing as creating a single
container pod
if you want to exec into one of the
container you simply use Cube CTL exec
Dash it the part name and specifying
Dash C and the container name this way
you can jump into one of the containers
running inside the pod
you get the logs for a container using
cubectl logs the Pod name Dash C the
container name
and this concludes this look at
multi-container pods
let's take a look at some networking
Concepts
kubernetes is what we call a flat
Network as a result most resources
inside a cluster can see each other
all containers within a pod can
communicate with each other
all pods can communicate with each other
all nodes can communicate with all pods
and all nodes
paws are giving an ephemeral IP address
while services are giving a persistent
IP so this is quite important we'll come
back to that later
let's illustrate the cluster Network in
blue here
each pod gets an IP address and the
containers inside a pod share the same
address space
the containers inside the same pod share
the same IP address but each must be
assigned a different port number
they can communicate inside the Pod
using localhost and the port number
they can also share the shared volumes
what about communication between pods
can the container on the right talk to
The Container inside the pod on the left
using localhost
no they can't
they need to go through a service that
will front the network traffic for the
pod
for external access to the cluster
traffic goes through a load balancer
service offered by the cloud provider
in future lectures we'll look at
different type of services that we can
use in kubernetes
and this concludes this quick look at
networking Concepts
thank you
let's create a multi-container pod using
a yaml file let's take a look at the
yaml file
so the kind is part
the name will be two dash containers
and in the container section we're
defining two containers so the first one
we'll use the nginx image and we'll name
it my nginx and that web server will
listen on Port 80.
and we're defining a second container
using the BusyBox image and we'll name
it my box
this one will listen on Port 81.
and for the BusyBox container to stay up
and running we need to tell it to to
stay up by issuing a sleep command so
it'll stay for an hour
what we'll try to achieve is open a
session on the BusyBox container and try
to hit the nginx container so the the
default web page served by the nginx
container
all right
let's try to create our
pod here using a cube CTL create and the
name of our yaml file
okay pad two dash containers created so
let's try to see uh if they're running
all right two out of two because we have
two uh containers running in that pod
status running 10 seconds uh the IP
address so there's one IP address
assigned to the to the pub
and denote okay let's try to get a
little bit more information by using the
cube Ctrl describe pod and the name of
the pod
let's scroll up a little bit
so the name is two containers then space
is the default one the node where it's
running uh the containers so the first
one is my nginx which using a the nginx
image
we have information about the limits
that we set earlier in the ml file my
box using a BusyBox image listing on
Port 81
right there's a that sleep command
so useful information here and also look
at the events now
so earlier when we add only one
container inside a pod we would get just
one set of events for polling and
creating the container now we have two
first one is the Pod was scheduled and
the second one here is on the second
land line
um the nginx image was in the polling
state it was Paul created started and
then the busy box container was pulled
and created
okay
perfect now let's try to open a session
inside our BusyBox container so we'll
use Cube CTL exec Dash it okay here's
the trick now we need to specify the Pod
name and then the container name that we
want to to connect to
and then the the program that we want to
run that's the trick when you have
multiple containers you need to specify
the Pod name and then the container name
all right let's try to do that
oh looks good at last yeah
it worked okay now we'll use wget to try
to hit that default page serve ID nginx
web server
wget with the this flag and we'll call
localhost
all right welcome to nginx so that word
now Outpost for a couple of seconds and
why I'm gonna ask you why did that work
why calling localhost worked
so that work because let's go back to
our yaml file
the nginx container is listening on Port
80. right we don't have to specify a
import number here
if the nginx container would have
listened to something different we would
have to specify Here Local O's colon and
the port number
all right let's try to exit this
perfect
let's now delete our pod using Cube CTL
delete and the name of the ml file and
by using the force and grease grace
period equals zero flag
that will kill both containers
immediately
perfect
[Music]
this is a super short lecture just to
introduce you to the concept of a
workload
so a workload is an application running
on kubernetes
all containers running in a kubernetes
cluster must run in a workload
the Pod is the atomic workload it
represents a set of running containers
and all workloads will create pods
the replica set and the deployment will
provide extra functionalities on top of
the pod
like the ability to Define how many
instances of a part we want
the stateful set and the Daemon set are
specialized workloads and finally the
job and crunch up offer tasks that run
to completion
these are short-lived tasks
we will see each of these workloads in
detail in the following lectures
and this concludes this super short
lecture on the workload concept
[Music]
let's take a look at replica set
the replica set primary job is to manage
d-pad replicas making sure that the
desired number of instances are running
this provides the self-e-link
capabilities in kubernetes
while you can create replica set the
recommended workload is the deployment
now welcome back to that in a moment
so let's say that you want three
instances of a pod to run at all time
you create a replica set and specify
that you want three replicas
if for some reason one bird crashes
kubernetes will replace it automatically
without any human intervention I'm
pretty cool eh
let's see how to define a Rebecca set by
starting with a pod
we take the Pod definition except for
the API version and kind
and we place these values in the
template section of the replica set
the final result is a replica set yaml
file
so basically in the section highlighted
in green
you will find values specific to replica
set and under the template section the
values that Define the Pod you want to
run
here you set the desired number of
instances with the replicas property
again while you can create replica sets
the recommended workload to use is the
deployment because it provides extra
functionalities on top of the replica
set
so why bother and learn about replica
sets
well in the deployment lecture you'll
see that when you create a deployment
that will also create a replica set in
the background
that's why it's important to learn about
the replica sets functionalities
here's a cheat sheet for replicasets
command
you create one using cubectl apply Dash
F and the yabl file
you get a list of the replicases by
using cubectl get RS
you get some information
about the replica set by using Cube CTL
describe RS and the replica set name
you delete one using Cube CTL delete
if you have the yaml file you specify
Dash F and the yaml file name or if you
don't have the yaml file simply by using
the replica set name using cubectl
delete RS and the replica set name
and this concludes this look at Olympic
assets
[Music]
let's create three instance of energy
next container using the replica set
template
so let's take a look at our yaml file
the type of object we want to create is
the replica set
this will be the name of the replica set
rs-example
we want three replicas running uh at the
same time
and uh we want three replicas of this
containers
uh name will be nginx and the image
nginx uh colon Alpine so it's a smaller
version and we Define the resources and
also the ports that each is listening on
all right
let's try to uh create that so Cube CTL
apply or create Dash F and the name of
our EML file
okay we'll pick a set created
let's take a look at our running pods
and have three pods running okay and
look at the names that were
um that were assigned to the each of
these spots RS Dash example and then is
some kind of a unique number here
each one must have a different or unique
name so each one is ready running and
look here each one has a different IP
address
perfect so let's take a look at our
replica sets that we've created so Cube
CDL get RS
so there's one
rs-example
um three desired three current three
ready
everything is green everything's okay
Let's uh now describe our replica set so
Cube CTL describe RS for replica set and
the name of our replica set
so let me paste that
right let's scroll up a little bit
so the name is RS example uh it's
running in the default namespace
um any labels or annotations are listed
here number of replicas that we set so
three current three desired and the the
current part the status S3 running
and zero failed
to The Container information so nginx we
want to run the nginx Alpine image the
sync on Port 80 the limits and so on and
this these are the events that were
raised here so each pod was successfully
created here
all right so last thing we need to
delete what created using qctl delete
Dash F and the name of the EML file
thank you
let's take a look at deployments
we'll start by comparing pods and
deployments
Buzz don't self-heal meaning that if a
pod dies kubernetes will not replace it
automatically
using a pod definition only one instance
can be created and you can't update and
roll back pods
deployment can
a deployment manages a single part
template so you create one for each
microservice you want to run
when creating a deployment this will
also create a replica set in the
background
but while you can see it
you don't interact with the replica set
directly you let the deployment manage
that for you
to summarize the replica set provides
the self-ealing and scaling
functionalities while the deployment
provides updates and rollback
functionalities
let's take a look at the deployment
definition
you define the desired number of
instances with the replicas property
this will be used by the underlying
replica set
you set the number of iteration you need
to keep using the revision history limit
property
and you set the update strategy in the
strategy section
you can set the strategy type to a
rolling update this way kubernetes will
cycle when updating the pods
the other strategy is recreate
kubernetes will take all existing pods
down before creating the new ones
we'll have a dedicated lecture on this
topic later on
like a replica set we start with a pod
definition
and we start the metadata section in the
template section of the deployment
the final deployment definition looks
like this
highlighted in green we see the
properties specific to the deployment
and in yellow the ones defining the Pod
we want to run
here's a cheat sheet for deployments
command
so if you don't want to use a yaml file
you can create a deployment using the
imperative way so you use Cube CTL
create deploy you specify a name
then with the image property you you
specify the image
replicas the number of replicas you want
to run and you can specify also other
properties like the port number that the
paths will listen on
if you have a yaml file well you simply
use Cube CTL apply Dash F and the yaml
file
you get a list of the deployments using
cubectl get deploy
and you get the deployment info using
cubectl describe deploy and the
deployment name
since a deployment will create also a
replica set you can get the list of the
replica set using cubectl get RS and you
delete a deployment by using a EML file
so Cube CTL delete Dash F the name of
the yaml file or if you don't have it
simply use Cube CTL delete deploy and
the deployment name
and this concludes this look at
deployments
thank you
[Music]
let's use the deployment template to
create three instances of an nginx
container
so let's take a look at the EML file
this time we want to use the deployment
Kai
type of object we want to create is the
deployment
we name it deploy example we want three
instances three replicas
and we want to keep three versions three
replica sets versions in the history in
site kubernetes
I know if you scroll down a little bit
we see that we want to run an nginx uh
the Alpine version because it's a little
bit smaller and we name it nginx we set
some resource limits and each pod will
listen on Port 80. all right quite
similar to the replica set template that
we saw earlier except maybe for uh this
parameter here
all right
now let's create our deployment using
cubesatel apply or create Dash F deploy
example
and let's get a list of the pods that
are currently running Cube CTL getbots
Dash o wide
and yes we have three parts three lines
here so look at the names uh given to
each bot so deploy example that's the
name of the deployment object
the the name of the deployment object
Dash something unique so to make sure
that each part has a unique thing
kubernetes as a random number like this
only one container is running inside
each bot uh it's in running State each
pod gets its own IP address
so that's perfect
okay let's now try to describe our pods
so we can use the cube CDL describe pod
and deploy example name but we just saw
that the the names work a little bit
different let's see if this works
yep it worked
it worked because uh the name is share
across uh these three parts and so we
get information about each one of these
let's say I just need the information
about that particular part I can use
that name uh the unique name also so
instead of deploy example I'm gonna use
the full name
and there it is f uh the information
about that pod
just that button
all right
let's now get some information about the
deployment
currently uh inside my cluster so
cubesatel get deploy I have only one
deploy Dash example three out of three
ready up to date available so
everything's uh looking good
and I can describe my deployment using
cubectl describe the name of the the
type of the object and then its name
all right so let's go a little bit we
have the name the namespace where it's
running any labels annotations number of
replicas three desired three updated
three total three available perfect
strategies rolling update
okay because we haven't set a running
update strategy that's the default one
we'll come back to that uh later on the
path template
nginx Alpine listening on Port 80.
right and the events here
all right
since a deployment will automatically
create a replica set let's take a look
at the replica set that was created so
Cube CTL get RS
and for sure we have one replica set
that was created by the deployment if we
desired three current we're ready
everything looks okay and we can also
describe our Republic asset since we
have only one we can uh use Cube CTL
describe RS or we can use its full name
we copy that
and here I have the replica set
description
and finally we need to do a little bit
of cleanup we delete our deployment
using Cube CTL delete and with the name
of the yaml file
thank you
let's take a look at demon sits
the demon set is a specialized workload
its role is to ensure that an instance
of a pod is running on all nodes
the paths are scheduled by the scheduler
controller and run by the demon
controller
as nodes are added to the cluster
the pods are added to them
typical views are running some kind of
helper service like a log collection or
some kind of monitoring
well let's illustrate that in this
cluster we have two nodes
and the demon workload ensures that an
instance of a pod is running on each one
of these nodes
so you define a demon set in a yellow
file
you can specify that you don't want to
schedule a pod on the master node by
using a toleration
same thing if you want to run the part
on specific node pools
here's a cheat sheet for the demon sets
command
so you create a demon set using a yaml
file with the cube CTL apply Dash F
command
you get a list of demon set using Cube
CDL get DS
you get some information about the
running demon set using cubectl describe
DS and the name of the demon set
and when you want to delete a demon set
you either use a yaml file using cubectl
delete Dash F and the name of the yaml
file or the name of the running Daemon
set by using Cube CTL delete DS and the
demon set name
and this conclude this look at demon
sets
[Music]
let's run a BusyBox image as a demon set
to ensure that we have one instance of
that container running on each node in
our cluster
so let's take a look at the yaml file
all right
the kind is demon set we give it a name
demon set Dash example
and the container that we'll run is a
busy box and here in the Toleration
section
we specify that
we don't want to schedule
a demon set on
a node role
that is mastered so we don't want to to
run that demon said that the Busy box uh
on the control plane on the masternode
all right
Let's uh
deploy our demon sets so here I'm I'll
be deploying that demand set on a
cluster in the cloud that has three
nodes because if I would try to do that
on Docker desktop with just one note
won't be interesting so let's try to do
that doesn't matter what cloud provider
I'm using right now
okay uh let's uh get a
a cube City I'll get parts we'll come
back to uh the rest just after that so
here I have three uh Parts demon example
with a unique name here let's uh add the
dash
oh wide
a flag
Let's uh examine the node column so you
can see that each pod is running on a
unique node so 0 3 and 4 here
and this selector is interesting because
it if you have multiple objects you can
basically filter out or just select what
you want so here selector says the app
uh equals the demon set example that's
the name of our object here
so that word one instance of our busy
box is running on each node
let me add a fourth node
all right so my note count is now four
let's go back to visual studio code and
let's rerun uh the get paths command
and for sure I have a Ford instance of
my BusyBox container running as a demon
set on the new note without me doing
anything it was deployed automatically
because I selected the demon set object
type
now we simply need to delete that demon
set using a cube CTL delete
[Music]
let's take a look at stateful sets
let's say that you run a database inside
your kubernetes cluster
traffic gets higher and you need to
scale that database
so you create more instances
the main one can read and write while
the other instances are in read-only
mode and use replicas of the main
database
this is a complex scenario to implement
the stateful set role is to help you
solve this complex problem
for parts that need to maintain state
and unlike a deployment a stateful set
maintains a sticky identity with a
persistent identifier for each of the
pods
and if a part dies it will be replaced
by another one using the same identifier
the stateful set will create the parts
in sequence
and delete them in reverse order
typical use are for Network related
services that maintain some State and
also for databases
each pod gets a unique identifier using
the stateful set name plus the sequence
number
and if one dies it is replaced by a new
one but with the same identifier
the pot creation is done in a ordered
way meaning that the first one will be
created then the second one and so on
and when they are deleted they are
deleted in the reverse order
note that the persistent volumes are not
automatically deleted
foreign
set you need to use a needless service
you define one by setting the cluster IP
value to none
the stateful set will then refer to the
atlas service
and you define cloud storage in the
volume claim templates section
let's represent this slide as you can
see only the first spot lets you read
and write so how can you reach it if you
want to write to the database
well you use the pad network name in
this case the instance name my SQL Dash
zero
plus the service name so dot MySQL
when reading simply use the service name
this will load balance the calls across
all instances
a bit of warning here
containers are stateless by default and
stateful sets are offering a solution
for a stateful scenario but a lot of
work has to be done on top of that
a better approach might be to use the
cloud provider database Services instead
of trying to fit a stateful scenario
inside your kubernetes cluster
lastly deleting a sitful set will not
delete the PVCs you have to do this
manually
here's a cheat sheet for stateful set
commands so you create one using the
cube CTL apply Dash F and the yaml file
you get a list of set full sets using
cubectl get STS you describe one using
cubectl describe SCS and the set for set
name
and you delete a simple set using the
delete command either using a yaml file
or the name of the stateful set
and this concludes this look at stateful
sets
[Music]
let's now create a stateful set
let's take a look at the state we'll set
that EML file there are two parts in
this CML file the first part is the
creation of the Headless service
the the kindest service
but the trick here is to set cluster IP
To None like this this will create an
endless service
all right second part is to create our
stateful set so the kind set will set
give it a name nginx Dash SCS and here
we're referencing our Atlas service here
so the name of our Atlas service
assigned to the service name property
we want three replicas
right of a nginx image
and we're creating a claim on a search
class name called Azure file so the
cloud provider here is not important
that will work on any cloud provider so
I already have a search class name
called Azure file we'll use the read
write once access mode and we'll use
when when gigabyte of storage and we'll
Mount this to a folder in VAR www
all right
so let's create our Seattle set here
Cube CTL apply Dash if
stateful set Dot yaml and quickly let's
do a cube CTL get but a white and here
you can see that the first
instance is running
the second one is running the third one
is pending so each instance will be
created in a sequence so the first one
zero the second one one the third one
two you can see by the age of each
instances so 19 seconds 14 and 9 seconds
they are created in a sequence and
deleted in a reverse order also
here we can see that um
there's an IP address assigned to each
of these
let's take a look at the PVCs we should
have a PVC for each of these instances
and yes SCS 0 1 and 2. so uh we can do a
mapping one to one here so for uh scs0
we have a PVC call also scs0 to prove
that let's uh describe the second one
let's say so Q
the L
describe paths and the number two and
let's see what the PVC is assigned what
claim is assigned
so here
the volume claim name scs-2
awesome
okay
what we'll do we'll create a file in the
in that instance the instance number two
and we'll delete the the Pod the Pod
will be recreated automatically and
we'll see if the file still exists we'll
also modify the default web page served
by nginx and see how we can reach that
that file the default web page from
another instance
so let's open a session on the nginx CS2
perfect
Let's uh CD in VAR
are volume and let's uh simply type Echo
and pipe that to
a file called echo.txt
I do it LS my file is there get
Hello dot txt yeah perfect
okay first step creating that file uh
Second Step modifying the default web
page let's CD into the user chair nginx
HTML folder
and let's do an LS here
so here's the default page served by
nginx index.html
we will brutally replace that file by
using cat and piping that to the file
name
and typing hello
enter Ctrl D on Windows to save the file
the file is there if I simply do a cat
index.html
yeah okay the file has been brutally
replaced
okay we'll close our session on this
instance so scs2 let's close our ins our
session
and let's open
a session on the instance zero
okay
awesome
let's try to it that default HTML page
but on the instance number two so nginx
as CS2 so to do that we'll need to use
the web the web address nginx scs2 so
that's the name of the instance dot the
name of the atlas service
and that word
would only the
hard name word
no you need a combination of boat
the instance name and the atlas service
also
all right let's exit our session here
okay let's try to delete uh the uh
instance number two
okay let's do a q that's CTL
get but
we have a new instance
uh that was created uh seven seconds ago
but the uh the name of the instance is
still the same
so instead of a random number here by
using a stateful set this will ensure
that the names will be the same
okay so let's
open a session
on the instance number two let's LS far
and here's our file
awesome
let's do our cleanup so we'll delete the
stateful set and we need to manually
delete dpvcs because simply deleting
this table set will not delete the PVCs
so let's do that
[Music]
let's take a look at jobs
are for short-lived task workloads
you start a job it executes and succeeds
or fails so job don't say memory they
don't wait for traffic
a job creates one or more pod and
ensures that a specific number of them
successfully terminate
the job tracks the successful part
completions and then marks the job as
complete when the desired number of
completion is reached
when using multiple Parts the job will
create them one after the other
they can also run in parallel
this is a job definition
you define how many paths you want to
run at the same time
you can set a deadline if needed
and the number of completions to reach
to Mark the job as complete
and you should set the restart policy to
never
so here's a cheat sheet for the jobs
command
you create a job the imperative way
using Cube CTL create job the job name
and the image name
using the declarative way with a yaml
file you use cubectl apply Dash F into
the yaml file name
you list the jobs by using cubectl
GitHub
you get some information by using
cubectl describe job and the job that is
currently running
and you delete jobs with either a yaml
file using cubectl delete Dash F or with
the job name Cube CTL delete job and the
job name
and this concludes this look at jobs
thank you
in this lab we'll create a simple job so
let's take a look at the chub yaml file
so the kind is chopped so that's the
type of object we're creating
uh the name we're giving it hello and
what we will run is a busy box container
and when the container starts it will
Echo uh hello front the job
perfect
something sip simple
Let's uh run this Cube CTL apply with
the name of our yaml file
perfect the job was created
okay let's get a list of the jobs
there's one
hello completion one so it ran
and duration was two seconds okay
let's do a cube CDL describe job since
we have only one job that will do the
work if not we can type the job name
hello
and uh but but let's take a look at name
hello namespace default
annotation and so on and so on it ran
One Time One succeeded
so that's our container
successfully create and complete it
perfect
now
we
can get a list of the pods using cubectl
get that and this is uh the Pod that was
created to run the job it's still there
you see the status completed
but it's still there so we can get to to
examine the log in case something went
wrong
so we can do Cube
CTL
logs and the name of the part here
hello from the job
that worked
so let's do our cleanup let's delete the
job
is deleted do we have any uh Parts left
none any chops left
none perfect
[Music]
let's take a look at crunch apps
a crunch up is a workload that runs jobs
on a schedule
it's an extension of the job that we saw
in the previous lecture
the schedule is defined using a crown
like syntax in UTC
and you can get more information about
the crown syntax in this Wikipedia page
here's a crunch out definition
you set the scheduled parameter to a
cron schedule
so how do you know if a crunch up ran
successfully
well you need to look at the job history
by default the last three successful
jobs
and the last fill job are kept
the paths will be in a stop State and
you'll be able to look at their logs
foreign
if you don't want to keep any history
you can set the successful job history
limit to zero
so here's a cheat sheet for the crown
job commands
you can create one using the imperative
way
and if you have a yellow file you use
the cube CTL apply Dash F and the name
of the yaml file
you can get the list of decron jobs
currently
running using cubectl get the CJ
you can get some information with the
cube CDL describe CJ and you delete the
crunch up using its CML file using Cube
CTL delete Dash F and the yaml file name
and if you don't have the yellow file
name you can delete it using cubectl
delete CJ and the crunch up that is
currently running
and this concludes this look at run jobs
[Music]
so let's create a crunch up we'll take a
look at the yellow file
kind is the crunch up I'm going to name
it hello Cron
and we will give it a schedule
only Stars which means that it will run
every 60 seconds every minute that's the
default
and we're going to run a busy box image
and we it will Echo this string
okay
so let's create our
job using cubectl apply
and we can get a list of the crown jobs
using cubectl get print jobs
okay so here we have the name the
schedule if it's suspended it's if it's
active the last last time it ran and we
can get some information using cubectl
describe run job and we pass the its
name hello Dash Cron
here
this is super useful for troubleshooting
the name the default name space it runs
on in the default namespace
we have the schedule here
how many jobs does it keep in its
history how many failed job is kept also
the the command that will run
oh
you can get a list of the pods
okay uh one per Ran So elocron with a
unique uh value here so it has uh
completed I'm gonna pause
um to let it run a few times
all right uh the job ran three times
well it the last one is still uh running
uh container creating Let me refresh
that so it's completed okay now
we can get the logs by using cubectl
logs and then the
job name
dpod name so hello from the crown chart
so by default the last three run of the
job are kept in the history and you can
configure that in the yaml file
let's delete our crunch up here
perfect and if again we type Cube CTL
get pads uh all the parts in in the
history basically are also deleted when
you delete the crunch up
[Music]
let's take a look at rolling updates
in a previous lecture we saw that using
deployments you can set the number of
paths instances using the replicas
parameter
and set a number of previous iterations
of the deployment to keep in kubernetes
we also saw that there are two update
strategies running a date and recreate
recreate is quite simple kubernetes will
shut down all the running paths and
create new ones after that
running update will cycle through
updating parts
all right let's illustrate that using
recreate all previous paths are deleted
and the New Path will be created after
that
this means that there might be a small
period of time where your microservice
might not be responsive
using the routing of this strategy
a pod is deleted and replaced by a new
one
then the next one and so on
there are two values that you can set to
help you with this process
Max search will tell kubernetes how many
parts can be created over the desired
number of pods
let's say that you you want three
instances in total
setting Max search to 1 will allow
creation of one additional pod on top of
these three desired ones and this while
the rolling update is running
Max unavailable is the opposite
is the maximum number of pulse that can
be unavailable during the update process
note that if you don't specify an update
strategy in the deployment manifest
communities will use a default strategy
of running update with Max Surge and Max
unavailable both set to 25 percent
so let's say that we want three
instances of a bot and we set max search
and Max unavailable to 1.
we're telling kubernetes that it's okay
to create one additional part on top of
the three desired one
and that's it's okay to have one part
less than the three desired one
when done the previous replica set is
kept
you set how many you want to keep with
the revision history limit property
here's a cheat sheet for running updates
you create of course your deployment
using cubectl apply Dash F and the name
of your yaml file
you get the progress of the update using
cubectl rollout status
you get the history of the deployment
using cubectl rollout history deployment
and the deployment name
you can roll back a deployment using
qctl rollout undo and the deployment
name that will roll back to the previous
version
or if you want to roll back to a
specific revision number
you add the two dash revision parameter
and this concludes this look at running
updates
[Music]
in this lab we will create a deployment
and later on update it to a new version
using a rolling update
so let's take a look at the yaml file
the kind of object we're using easy
deployment call Lo Dash dab we want
three replicas and we're using a rolling
update strategy here and setting a Max
search to 1 and Max unavailable to one
we will deploy a container called Lo
Dash app yeah hello app and uh that'll
be version one and later on we will
update it to version 2. okay
so let's create our deployment here
okay we can get a the deployment status
by using Cube CTL rollout status
and the deployment name
uh the deployment was successfully
rolled out let's take a look at our
pods running
okay so I have three instances perfect
yellow depth uh three times excellent
let's describe the uh the deployment so
Cube CDL describe uh deploy and the
deployment name
and let's try to find if we can get some
information about the strategy yeah here
it is rolling update strategy Max
unavailable oh wow the strategy type is
right here uh rolling update
running update strategy Max and
available One Max search to one so you
can get that information that we set
earlier in the yml files okay
let's now see if we have a replica set
here's our replica set
and let's Now update
our yaml file and change the version of
Hello app to version 2. so just update
to 2 and save the file
and we will use cubesatel apply and with
the same yaml file
now what I'm going to do
how I'm using right now A K9s it's a
terminal dashboard in a terminal sorry
and to get the visual view of what's
what will happen basically so right now
I have three parts in green these are
the ones that are deployed let's apply
our new deployment I'm going to switch
quickly to K9s and you can see oh it
happens so fast
but
is you saw that the the new pods were
were created and the old ones were uh
were shut down
all right
here I can have a a deployment status
everything's fine if not we would have
uh some information if the deployment
would take longer we would have some
information printed here
okay how many uh replica sets do we have
we have two
uh the the current one so that's the
current one and the previous one
by default uh three uh versions are kept
uh in history
we can get the deployment history by
using cubectl rollout history and the
deployment name
okay version one for version two
okay we're at version two and
um we want to downgrade basically our
roll back to the previous version so you
can do
that by using Cube CTL rollout undo and
the deployment name so by default it
will roll back to the previous version
or if you have multiple versions and you
know what version you want to roll back
to you can specify the flag to revision
and the revision number as we see here
foreign
let's do this one
well either one will do the same thing
okay let me switch to K9s and see what's
happening oh the other one the the older
while the version two is uh terminating
new version is created
and we can get a deployment status here
everything successfully wrote
okay
Let's uh now take a look at our replica
sets
so we still have two
right
the current one is now
the the first one that we uh that we
deployed
all right and we can do our cleanup by
deleting the deployment using the yaml
file
[Music]
let's take a look at blue green
deployments
so let's say that version 2 of our macro
service contains some breaking changes
like a different database schema
what do you do
using the rolling update strategy you'll
have both version 1 and version 2 of
your app running at the same time
that might not work at all
so using the blue green deployment
pattern that might help solve that
problem
blue identify what's in production and
green identify a new version currently
deployed but not yet in production
notice that the pulse label contains the
version number
when ready simply update the service
definition to point to the new version
and now green is now in production
so green becomes blue and blue becomes
green
oh great this means that this pattern is
solving the new database schema problem
well not entirely you may still have to
deal with some downtime while you update
your database
and also another drawback is that since
both version of the macro services will
be up and running at the same time
you need to have enough free resources
in your cluster to make this possible
and this concludes this look at the blue
green deployments pattern
[Music]
in this lab we'll create a blue green
deployment
we have three yaml files here so let's
take a look at the lodep V1
it's a deployment
we want three replicas of a container of
a an image called Hello app
1.0 and here we're setting a label
of app lov1
now let's take a look at the second one
it's basically the same thing so
deployment three replicas
but it will use version 2 of our hello
App application and we're setting the
this label Here app to lov2
all right
let's take a look at our cluster IP
manifest file so it kind of service and
here's the selector app hello V1
we will deploy that and later on we will
change
the cluster IP manifest to point to the
newer version
okay so let's deploy version one of our
pods
and let's also deploy
our cluster IP service
so let's take a look at the list of the
paths currently running there are three
pods and also there should be
uh if I type Cube City I'll get SVC
one cluster IP as we see front that's
the one I just deployed perfect
so let's do a quick port forward
to uh to connect to our cluster IP
service so we'll port forward uh the
port 8080 that the cluster IP is
listening to to localhost 8080.
here cubesatel port forward service the
name of our service 8080 28080 and let's
hit local OS on port 8080 here
okay
so here hello world version
1.0 excellent day
okay
let's now deploy version two so uh right
in my phenomenal I'll hit Ctrl C on my
windows keyboard to break that and uh
gain my terminal back perfect
let's deploy
version two
okay and let's get a list of our pods
currently running should be six
so I have both versions uh in memory at
the same time
okay so that's one of the drawback of
this uh this technique this blue green
deployment technique
okay let's now it did the cluster IP
manifest file so we're we will change
the selector to select app on Lo
V2
let's save the file
and let's update our cluster IP service
by using cubectl apply and the name of
the yaml file
yes
okay
Let's uh port forward again
right let's hit that local OS again
and there you go V2
it worked
let's do a little bit of her clean up uh
let's delete our first deployment our
second deployment and also decluster IP
service
you can select the three lines at the
same time
[Music]
let's take a look at the concept of
service in kubernetes
first what problem do Services try to
solve
well if the pod in green need to reach
the pod in purple
you need to use its IP address
the problem is that pass yet ephemeral
IP addresses
if the part in purple dies well you
replace it
and the new one will have a different IP
address
so we need a way to make these calls
between pods a lot more robust
so back to the service what exactly is
the service well it's a kubernetes
object that you define in a yaml file
but on my pods
that have ephemeral IP addresses
Services get durable IP addresses and
also they get DNS names
they serve as ways to access Parts
they're kind of a middleman
and the target pods using selectors
here we have four pods and a service
the service select the pods that have
the Zone label equals to prod and the
version label equal to one
the first part satisfies the selector
the second one also
but not the third one
and not the last one
so only the first two are selected
so let's say we have two instances of a
pod and we place a service in front of
them
if another part needs to reach these
ones
it will go through the surface
and then the service will load balance
the request to the instances
in kubernetes we can use these Services
the cluster IP the node port and the
load balancer
note that the cluster IP is the default
service
we will look at them in more details in
the next lectures
and this concludes this quick look at
the concept of services in kubernetes
[Music]
let's take a look at the cluster IP
so what is a cluster IP well it's the
default service in kubernetes
its visibility is cluster internal this
means that it's not possible to use a
cluster IP service to reach a macro
service from the internet from outside
the cluster
in the cluster IP definition you can set
two different ports
Port is the port that the service will
listen on
and Target Port is the port that
deselected pods are listening on so the
cluster IP will route incoming traffic
to that board
in this CML file the service listens on
Port 80 and Route the traffic to Port
8080.
traffic is load balanced across the
selected paths
so when do you use a cluster IP service
well to provide a durable way to
communicate with pods but from inside
the cluster
so let's illustrate this
here we have a cluster IP service
fronting three instances of a pod
it's impossible to reach it from outside
the cluster but it's okay it's visible
from inside the cluster
this cluster IP will listen on Port ad
and select the paths using these two
labels
since the selected pods are listening on
port 8080 the service Target Port must
also be set to 8080.
this way the parts in green that want to
communicate with the ones in purple well
they go through the cluster IP service
on Port 80 and the service route the
traffic to Port 8080.
so let's say you have multiple Marco
Services uh you place a cluster IP in
front of each of them
because a cluster IP service IP address
is durable
while the pods ones are ephemeral
here's a cheat sheet for cluster IP
so the first two commands are imperative
commands let's say you already have a
pod running and you want to expose it
using a cluster ID
so you would use Cube CTL expose Oh
short for path the Pod name specifying
the the port and the Target Port and you
can also give a name to your to your
service
if you have a deployment you can also
use Cube CTL expose deploy the
deployment name specifying the port and
the target board so both commands are
imperative commands
if you have a yaml file you would use
Cube CTL apply Dash F and specifying the
EML file name
you can get a list of the services
running using cubectl get SVC
I get a little bit more information
specifying uh the flag Dash o and wide
you can also describe the service using
a cube CTL describe SVC and the service
name
and you can delete the cluster IP
service using the yaml file with the
cube CTL delete Dash F and the name of
the yaml file or cubectl delete SVC and
the name of the service
and this concludes this look at the
clusterity
[Music]
in this lab we will deploy an nginx
container front it with a cluster IP
service and then deploy a BusyBox
container open a session on that BusyBox
container and try to hit the web page
served by the nginx container but
through the cluster IP service all right
let's take a look at our yaml file we'll
start with the deployment one
kind is a deployment we want three
instances of the Pod and we will run the
nginx image the Alpine version and it
will list it on Port 80. now we're
setting two labels here and the cluster
IP service will you will select uh the
pods using these two labels so app
example environment prod all right let's
take a look at our cluster IP
kind service
it's gonna listen on port 8080 and it
will redirect the traffic to Port 80 on
the nginx containers all right
the selector is here so app example
environment broad so that will select
our pods uh in our deployment
perfect
so let's try to do that first let's uh
deploy the service
and let's deploy the
nginx containers
let's also deploy the busy box
and we can take a look at this it's a
kind of pod the name is my box and uh
it'll run a busy box image okay
so now let's get a list of our Bots
currently running
we should add four
one two three four so the first three
ones are the deployment the nginx images
and the fourth one is the BusyBox
all right
let's try to connect to the BusyBox
container open a session by using
cubectl exec my box Dash it and the name
of program we want to run perfect at
work by type LS yep okay let's try to
use the service to reach the nginx pods
so wget
and HTTP SVC example colon 880 so let's
try to run that and see if it works
okay that worked why did it work so what
is that name here
if we go back to the cluster IP
definition
that's the name of our service
and it's listening on Port 8080.
the service name Colin d uh the port
that is listening on
and that's it we can now exit our
session on our busy box and we can
delete
our resources the cluster IP the
deployment and the pod
thank you
[Music]
let's take a look at the note Port
service
what is a note port a noteboard extends
the cluster IP service and provides
extra functionalities
its visibility is internal like a
cluster IP but also external to the
cluster
you can set a third port using the note
Port property
this is the port that the service will
listen on outside the cluster
note that the port must be in a range
between 30 000 and 32 767.
and if you don't specify a note Port
value well kubernetes will assign one
randomly
you then set the port and the Target
Port Properties like you do with a
cluster IP
this sounds like a good way to expose
our macro services to external traffic
but this range between 30 000 and 32
767 it's kind of annoying because you
can't set it to let's say port 80.
and One requirement for using note ports
is that nodes must have public IP
addresses
to access your service simply specify
any node Port IP address plus the note
port
and the traffic will be routed to the
right note Port service inside the
cluster
the way it works is that you set the
pods and the service just like you did
before with the cluster IP but this time
you also specify a port number in the
note Port property
external communication uses the node IP
address and the port set with the node
Port property
internal communication uses the port set
in the port property just like a cluster
IP
now let's take a look at our note Port
cheat sheet
if you already have a pod running in
your cluster and you want to expose it
using a note Port service simply use the
cube CTL expose bow the Pod name
specifying the port and the Target Port
and the note Port as the type
now you may wonder where do you specify
the note port number
well you can't there's no properties
letting you set know that value between
30 000 and 32 767.
so communities will assign one randomly
for you
same thing for a deployment let's say
you have a deployment already running in
your cluster and you want to expose it
using a note Port you use cubectl expose
deploy the deployment name
Port Target Port type which is note port
and you can specify your name also
you can define a node port in a yaml
file and deploy it using cubesatel apply
Dash F the name of the yaml file you
list the services using cubectl get SVC
get more info adding Dash o wide
he can describe your service using
cubesatel describe SVC and the service
name
if you have a yaml file you can delete
it using the that file using cubectl
delete Dash F the name of the yaml file
or you can delete your service using its
name with qctl delete SVC and the
service name
and this concludes this look at the note
Port service
[Music]
in this lab we will expose a deployment
using a note Port service we have two
yable files let's take a look at them
the first one is for the deployment we
will deploy an engine X image the Alpine
version listening on Port 80.
and we will need to replicas perfect
let's take a look at the noteboard yaml
file kind is service
and the type is noteboard
and the selector will select our
deployment
and here we set our node Port 32 410
okay
now let's open a terminal
and we'll start by the deployment
cubesatel apply
and our yaml file next our service Cube
CTL apply
noteboard.yaml awesome let's make sure
that our pods are running
Cube CTL getbots Dash o wide
awesome two parts two instance of our
nginx container
all right now since we're using Docker
desktop the docker desktop node is
mapped to local OS to reach the note
Port service we need to use local OS
plus the note port
let's try that
local Post
32 410
and it worked awesome
Now when using a cloud provider you
would need to get a node IP address
instead of using the Local Host
you would get that IP address by using
cubectl get nodes Dash o wide
and here in the external IP address
colon you would find the external IP
address of the node
awesome let's do our cleanup let's
delete our note port and our deployment
[Music]
let's take a look at the concept of
surfaces in kubernetes
what problem do Services try to solve
well if the pad in green need to reach
the purple one
it needs to use its IP address
the problem is that pods are ephemeral
if the purple one dies you need to
replace it
and the new one will have a different IP
address
we need a way to make these calls
between pods more robust
so what exactly is a service
a service is a kubernetes object that
you define in a yaml manifest
unlike parts that have ephemeral IP
addresses
Services gets durable IP addresses and a
DNS name
they serve as a way to access paths and
they target pods using selectors
here we have four pods and a service
the surface selects the paths that have
the Zone label equals to prod and the
version label equals to V1
the first part satisfies the selector
the second one also
but not the third one and the last one
only the first two are selected
let's say that we have two instances of
a pod and we place a service in front of
them
if another part needs to reach these
parts it will go through the service and
the surface will load balance the
requests to these instances
in kubernetes we can use these services
D cluster IP the note Port the load
balancer and the Ingress
the cluster IP is the default service
its visibility is internal only
the note Port can expose a pod outside
the cluster
the load balancer and the Ingress are
similar Services they let you expose
applications outside of the cluster
one operates at D layer 4 and the other
at layer 7.
L4 L7 what's that
download balancer operates at the layer
4. that's the TCP transport level so
that's very low in the transport stack
it means that the load balancer can do
simple operations like round robin
routing
the Ingress operates at the higher level
in the transport stack
think of protocols like HTTP or SMTP
it's more intelligent so you can
configure complex routing rules okay no
worries if this sounds complex for now
simply remember that an Ingress is like
a load balancer but more intelligent
and this concludes this look at the
concept of services
[Music]
in this lab we will create a load
balancer service
but you may be may be asking yourself
we're not using a cloud provider right
now how can that work
well Docker desktop is helping us it
will emulate the load balancer service
so we can test our load balancer locally
awesome let's take a look at the
application
it's a simple deployment we want to
replicas two instances of an nginx image
super simple
and the the load balancer yaml file
kind is service the type is load
balancer
it will listen on port 8080 and redirect
traffic to the Pod that is listening on
Port 80.
all right
all right so let's open a terminal
okay
and let's deploy the app
and the load balancer
perfect let's make sure that our pod are
running by using Cube CDL getbots
yes I have two uh my coupons are here
perfect now
to get the IP address of the load
balancer we use Cube CTL get SVC Dash o
wide
foreign
S as the IP address
using a cloud provider load balancer
service you would find here instead of
local OS the public IP address of the
load balancer so let's test this open a
browser and type localhost 8080
and that works we reach our nginx pod
awesome
let's do our cleanup let's delete our
load balancer
and our application
[Music]
this is an introduction to the
persistent Concepts in kubernetes
we saw this slide earlier
containers are ephemeris and stateless
and any data stored in them is deleted
when the container is destroyed
so we need to find a way to store data
outside the containers if you want to
keep that data
so volumes let containers store data
into external storage systems
these are storage services offered by
the cloud providers
Defenders create plugins according to a
specification called the container
storage interface
and there are two ways to use storage in
the cloud the static way and the dynamic
way we have separate lectures on these
later on
all right the cloud providers create
plugins
to expose their storage Services as
persistent volumes and storage class
these two are kubernetes objects
next we will look at the static and
dynamic ways
[Music]
let's see how to use the static way
persistent volumes or PV and persistent
volume claims are PVCs
are two kubernetes objects that lets you
define and use external storage
a purchasing volume represents a storage
resource that is available cluster wide
and is provisioned by the cluster
administrator
you then use a persistent volume claim
to claim the persistent volume
a part will then use the PVC to mount a
local folder
PVCs can be used by multiple parts and
inside the parts all the containers are
sharing the same volume
there are many persistent volumes
plugins available some are offered by
the cloud providers
the one highlighted in yellow called
hostpath is a special one
it's a plugin available with kubernetes
that allow you to do local testing
and it's not mapped to a cloud provider
storage service
it will not work in a multi-node cluster
but it's super useful for local testing
here's the main drawback of persistent
volumes let's say that the cluster admin
provision 100 gigabytes of storage
and that the Pod only requires a small
portion of this storage let's say just
one gigabyte of that 100 gigabytes in
total so just one gigabyte well
too bad for the other pods because the
volume is used exclusively by the Pod
who has the claim on it
this can be a waste of precious
resources and we will see how storage
class get around this problem in the
next lecture
okay in the meantime let's focus on the
PV and the PVC
you first select the cloud provider
storage service you want to use
then you create a persistent volume and
set the required capacity let's say here
10 gigabytes
you then create a PVC so a claim
that refers to the persistent value
and finally you use the PVC from your
pod and mount a local folder on it
there's an inputs and property that you
must be aware of it's the reclaim policy
set a delete all data will be lost when
the claim on the volume is released
and this is the default value so be
aware of this
if you want to keep your files when the
PVC is released
you have to set the reclaim policy to
retain
again the default value is delete so be
careful and be aware of this
there are three access modes possible
using read write mini the volume can be
mounted as read write by many parts
using read-only mini the volume can be
mounted read-only by many parts
and finally with read write once the
volume can be mounted as real read write
Sorry by one single path and the other
parts will be in read-only mode
this might be useful if you have a main
worker that writes data and the other
pods simply read the data
you define a person in volumes using the
purchasing volume kind and you specify
the capacity
the access mode and the reclaim policy
in the spec section
in this example the ospad plugin is used
to access local storage
remember to only use hostpat for local
testing and refer to the storage
provider documentation and on how to
create a persistent volume specific for
their storage service
you then Define a claim so a persistent
value claim making sure that the access
mode match the one set in the processing
value
in this case the claim is for 8
gigabytes out of the possible 10
gigabytes set on the persistent volume
this means that no one can claim the
remaining two gigabytes until the claim
is released
in the volume section of your pod
definition
simply refer to the PVC and mount a
local folder on it
a persistent volume can have these
states
available meaning that the resource is
free and not currently in use
bound the volume is bound to a claim so
it's in use it's not available anymore
release the claim has been deleted but
the resource is not yet reclaimed by the
cluster
and finally failed well something's
wrong
here's a cheat sheet for the PV and PVC
commands
using a yaml file you can create either
a PV or PVC by using cubectl apply Dash
F and the name of the yaml file
you get the install persistent volume
using cubecti Cube CTL getpv
the claims using cubectl get PVC you can
describe them cubectl describe PV or PVC
with their name you can delete them
using their yaml file cubicle delete F
and the name of the yaml file or by
using their name so Cube CTL delete PV
and the PV name or the PVC name
and this concludes this section as the
static way next we'll take a look at the
dynamic way
[Music]
in this lab we will create a persistent
volume a persistent volume claim and use
a pod to mount a local folder on that
storage
we will create that in Docker desktop
locally using the host path plugin all
right so let's first take a look at the
persistent volume yaml file
the kind is purchasing value we give it
a name pv001
and a storage capacity 10 megabyte
access mode read write once and we set
the processing volume reclaim policy to
retain
and use that host Pat plugin here and to
map to a folder in the docker desktop
virtual machine to data here
all right
let's take a look at the PVC
kind persistent volume claim we give it
the name my claim read write access mode
must be the same as the PV persistent
volume so let's double check read write
once
on the PV read write once on the PVC
awesome
we request 10 megabytes of storage so we
record the full capacity we could have
chosen a lesser value if you want all
right
let's take a look at the Pod now
so it's uh the kind of pod it's a busy
box
and uh we make a reference to the claim
here in the volumes section we give it a
name and we reference the persistent
volume claim called my claim
this guy here
okay
and we use that name mypd and we mount
it to a local folder called demo we
should see magically appear a folder
called demo inside our BusyBox container
okay let's deploy our persistent volume
right
percent in volume pv01 created awesome
let's look at the PV
qctl getpv
name
pv001 capacity 10 megabyte read write
once reclaim policy to retain it's
available it's not claimed
uh awesome so let's now deploy the claim
the PVC
persistent volume claim my claim created
awesome Cube CTL get PVC
my claim it's bound to the volume called
pv001 capacity 10 megabytes
read write once and let's again take a
look at the PV to see if something has
changed
yep it's now bound the status is bound
to the claim called
my claim running in the default name
space
awesome
so let's now uh deploy our pod
okay my PC box was created let's connect
to it using Cube CTL exec the name of
the instance so the Pod Dash it and the
program you want to run
so let's do NLS and see if we see a demo
folder and there it is we have our demo
folder
Let's uh CD into that folder and let's
create a a file inside
cat and we'll pipe that to uh lo.txt
let's type hello world world
uh if I can type
Ctrl D to exit and save the file Let's
do an LS to see if the file was created
perfect
okay
let's exit this session
and now let's delete the pod
let's delete the part by using cubectl
delete Dash F pod and since the busy box
takes uh 30 seconds to shut down we will
force it to do it right away we don't
want to wait
okay
Let's uh deploy it again well
Cube CTL
rctl get the pods no resource awesome
it's really dead
Let's uh deploy it again
okay
Let's uh open a session
CD demo LS all right and let's get that
file
hello a car cat cat nut car
hello world awesome it worked
Let's uh exit our session
let's now do our cleanup we'll delete
our bud
and then we will delete the PVC
right
and then the PV
so you can't delete the PV before the
PVC well you can issue the command but
the the command will be in kind of a
weight State uh until uh the PVC has
been released
[Music]
let's continue our journey into
persistence by looking at the dynamic
way
so here's a new object the storage class
and the search class represent a storage
resource that is available cluster wide
and is provisioned by the cluster
administrator
you don't have to set a capacity
and it eliminates the need for the admin
to pre-provision a persistent value
now compared with processing volumes
where once a claim has been made
the remaining capacity becomes
unavailable
well the storage class can support many
claims many persistent volume claims
so you first select the cloud provider
storage service that you want to use
you create a storage class
so here no need to specify a capacity
then you create a PVC the claim that
refers to the storage class and now you
specify the required capacity
and finally you use the PVC in your pod
and mount a local folder
like a persistent volume there's an
important property that you must be
aware of it's the reclaim policy set at
delete all data will be lost when the
claim is released and it's the default
value also like the persistent volume so
be aware
if you want to keep your files when the
PVC is released you have to set the
reclaim policy to retain again the
default value is delete
again three access modes possible and
they are set using the PVC not the
storage class
read write mini the volume can be
mounted as read write by many pods read
only mini the volume can be mounted
read-only by many pods
and lastly read write once the volume
can be mounted as read write by a single
part and the other parts will be in
read-only mode
useful if you have a main worker that
writes data and the other pods simply
read the data
so
you first start defining a storage class
specifying the cloud provider driver
with the provisioner property and
additional settings in the parameters
section
so refer to the source provider
documentation on how to create a
specific storage class further storage
service
you then Define a PVC specifying an
access mode
and the source capacity required
in this claim uh the claim is for 5
gigabytes
but more PVCs can be created over that
storage class
then simply refer to the PVC in your
path definition and map a local folder
on it
in summary the main benefits of a
storage class versus a purchasing volume
is that with a storage class you don't
have to define a capacity
and multiple Claims can be made
here's a cheat sheet for storage class
at Men's so you create your storage
class using a yaml file using Cube CTL
apply Dash F and your the name of your
yaml file
you get a list of your storage classes
or PVCs using get the SC for search
class and get PVC
you get the search as information by
using cubectl described as C and the
class name
you delete your search class and PVC
using cubectl delete Dash F and the yaml
file name or you delete your search
class using delete SC and the class name
or delete PVC and the PVC name
and this concludes this section about
persistence using the dynamic way
[Music]
let's see how to store configuration
values using config Maps
in a previous lecture we saw that it was
possible to place configuration values
directly in the environment section of a
pod definition
but what if we need to change that value
well we have to edit the Manifest and
redeploy the container
also usually it's not a best practice to
tie an object with its configuration so
how can we externalize these values
the config map object allow you to
decouple and externalize configuration
values
the key value pairs are then injected in
the containers as environment variables
they can be created from yaml files
a series of text files or even folders
containing files
they are static meaning that if you
change the value the containers that
refer to these values have to be
restarted to get these refresh values
using a yaml file you define a config
map and place the key value pairs in the
data section
you can even specify multi-line values
using the pipe character
in the EnV section environment section
of the container definition
you define an environment variable and
by using value from an config map key
ref
you reference the config back name and
the key as defined in the config map
so in the config map key ref section
name refers to the config map name and
key refers to a key in the config map
earlier I mentioned that this is a
static process meaning that the values
are injected when kubernetes starts the
container
this means that if you make a change to
a config map value
inside the container the original values
stay the same until you restart the
container
to get around this you can map a volume
on a config map Yes you heard it right
mounting a volume
this solves the static issue and updates
are reflected in containers
each key value pair is seen as a file in
the mounted directory
so we start with a config map
then use a volume to mount it to a local
folder inside our pod our container
the result is that all key value pairs
are now scenes as file
the name of the file being the key
and the value being inserted in the file
while this sounds cool it also means
that you'll have to refactor your code
so instead of reading environment
variables
you'll have to read files
so is it worth it you'll have to figure
out that by yourself
here's the config Maps cheat sheet so if
you're adventurous you can create a
config map from the command line that's
the imperative Way by using Cube CTL
create config map you give it a name and
with the from Dash literal parameter you
specify the key value pairs so you can
specify multiple key value pairs of the
same line
or you can use a good old yaml file and
use cubectl apply Dash F and the name of
your yaml file you can create a config
map using cubectl Create CM specify your
name and specifying a the name of a text
file containing multiple key value pairs
also you can create a config maps from a
folder so if you have multiple files
inside your folders you can create a
config map from that
you can get a list of the config maps by
using cubectl getcm
you can output the config map in a yaml
file by using cubectl get CM the name of
the config map and the dash o parameter
with the yaml and you can pipe that to
to a file name
of course you delete a config map by
using its yaml file using cubectl delete
Dash F and the name of the yaml file
and this concludes this uh look at
config Maps
[Music]
in this app we're going to create a
config map and use a pod that will
reference a value stored in that config
map
let's take a look at the config map
so the kind is config map
we have a name
cm-example and in the data section we
have two key value pairs date as set to
Michigan and City and our board all
right
so let's now take a look at our pod
tiny spot
uh it's a busy box
and here in the environment section
we declare in environment variable that
we will call City
and we are getting the value from
a config map key ref
right and we specified the name of the
config map so cm-example
that's the name of the config map
and the key is City
so here
that's the key right there
okay
again environment section
we Define a new environment variable
that we will call City we get the value
from config map key ref
specifying the name of the config map
and the key
awesome
let's create our config map
okay Cube CDL gets cm to get information
about our config map
so CM example
two data
okay that doesn't give us much
information well about the data itself
so let's do a cube Studio describe
config map
CM example
okay
we have the name the namespace where it
is any labels annotations and here we
have uh the data section City and
Airport State Michigan
and if for some reason you want to
Output that as a yamo uh Cube CDL get
config map the name of the config map
Dash o output in yaml
uh to recreate the config map using this
let's now deploy the pod
or BusyBox
perfect let's open a session
Cube CDL exec
my box
Dash it and the program you want to run
and let's display the city environment
variable let's Echo that Echo dollar
sign City and there it is an arbor so
that worked foreign
exit
and we can do a little bit of cleanup we
can delete our config map
and we can delete our busy box spot
[Music]
let's see how to use the secrets object
in kubernetes you will find many times
of Secrets types
the default one is the OPAC type
and it is very similar to the config
Maps object that we saw in the previous
lecture
you can also store credentials to
connect to private container registries
authentication secrets
and even certificates
in this lecture we will focus on the
OPEC Secret
like config Maps secrets are used to
store configuration values so they are
somewhat identical to config Maps except
that these store values as base64
encoded strings
and it's important to understand that
base64 is a way to encode strings
and it is not an encryption algorithm
this means that Secrets stored in
kubernetes can be decoded quite easily
yeah great since these secrets are Noah
very secret should you use them
well the answer depends on the type of
information you want to store
it might be okay to store a connection
to a database but it might not be for
something more sensitive
you can protect Secrets using role-based
access control policies are back
or you can store them elsewhere all
Cloud providers offered ways to store
secrets in Seeker Vault services
that you can retrieve firm kubernetes
you can also use a third party tool like
the very popular Vault product from
archicup just be aware that the
kubernetes default secret the OPEC one
is not encrypted by default in
kubernetes
so you can define a secret in a manifest
and use a base64 encoded strings as the
values
or use the command line where you can
use plain text strings
easier
in the path definition you simply get
the secret value using the secret key
ref section
this is very similar to config Maps
and again similar to config maps you can
mount a volume on top of Secrets
here's the container registry secret and
you can Define it using a yaml file or
with the CLI
next in the path definition you
reference the credentials in the image
pull Secrets section
here's a cheat sheet for Secrets
commands
so you can create a secret the
imperative way at the common line if you
want using cubesdl Create secret generic
and then the secret name and you pass
the key value pairs with the from Dash
literal per meter you can of course
create one using a yaml file so cubesdl
apply Dash F and the name of the yaml
file you can get a list of the secrets
using cubectl gets secrets
you can output the secret to a yaml file
by using cubectl get Secrets the secret
name and the dash o yaml parameter and
you can pipe that to a a file you can
delete the secret using a yaml file or
using the secret name using cubectl
delete secrets and with the secret name
and this concludes this look at secrets
[Music]
in this lab we'll create a secret and
from a pod we will reference secret and
use them as environment variable
let's take a look at our secrets at yaml
file
the type or the kind is secret we give
it a name secrets and in the data
section we have key value pairs so
username to some value and password to
some value notice that the
values but must be base64 encoded you
cannot put a non-encoded string here
how do you do that on Windows base64 the
the tool is not installed by default so
you can use these two websites basics of
foreign code.org decode.org
or you can install base64 using
chocolati as shoko installed base64 on
macro Linux well it's already installed
so you simply do something like that you
Echo your string and you pipe that to
base 64.
and that will encode the string and let
me copy that
and to decode Echo
uh the encoder string and you pipe that
again to base64
Dash D for decode and voila
all right
from the Pod now let's take a look at
our pod yaml definition
kindness part it's a busy box and here
in the environment variable we're
creating two environment variable the
first one is called username and it gets
its value from a secret key ref
and the name references the secret name
here
and the value well the key is one of
these two
so username or password Here
a case key reference here the username
from the secrets Secret
and second one is password a the
environment variable is called password
and we get the value from the secrets
secret and the key is password awesome
let's create the secret
all right let's get a list of the
secrets
here's our secret if it has two data it
was created six seconds ago we can
describe it cubicity of describe the
object type and then it name
and here what do we have the name
namespace and well we don't see the
secret just the the keys here
and what if we use Cube CTL get secrets
and output that to demo
the
secret data password say
uh
doing a describe would not allow us to
see the values but using get secret and
outputting that to a yaml will allow us
to retrieve the actual values
okay
let's now deploy our busy box
right let's open a session
and let's Echo uh username
D username and the password
whoops Echo
uh
password
my password so that that works
the uh the values the secrets are
decoded when they're injected into into
the pods
let's exit that and let's delete our
secret
and let's delete our busy box
[Music]
let's talk about observability
if you deploy a container using a
deployment and it crashes kubernetes
will create a brand new instance of the
pod
this works because kubernetes monitors
the infrastructure
but what about your application
if your app crashes well kubernetes will
look at the Pod health and see that it's
still running
so from the infrastructure point of view
everything is working fine your bud is
still up and running but your code
inside the Pod has crashed
would it be nice if kubernetes could
monitor the application health
well you can achieve this by configuring
probes
the startup probe informs a kubernetes
that the container has started and it's
now okay to send traffic to it
the Readiness probe enforced kubernetes
that the container is now ready to
accept traffic
let's say that when your app starts it
needs to execute a series of steps like
getting some configuration values from a
database creating some files and so on
and so on and let's say that this
startup sequence takes around 30 seconds
so even if your container is up and
running your code is not ready to accept
traffic
so using a Readiness probe you tell
kubernetes to wait 30 seconds before
starting to send traffic
lastly the liveness probes tell
kubernetes if your app is still running
and if not kubernetes will kill the Pod
and replace it with a brand new one
here's a part definition with the three
possible probes
the starter probe tell kubernetes to
wait for 10 seconds before making an
HTTP call to a page called health
the failure threshold tells kubernetes
to try three times
the Readiness probe tell kubernetes to
wait initially five seconds before
probing and making a TCP call on port
8080 and then check every 10 seconds
the liveness probe tell kubernetes to
wait initially for 15 seconds before
probing by making a TCP call on port
8080 and then check every 20 seconds
note that the Readiness probe will run
during the whole pod life cycle
but will these two Conflict at some
point
yes and no they will run simultaneously
but a fail probe will result in
different actions from kubernetes
failing a Readiness probe will tell
kubernetes to stop sending traffic to
the pod
but the Pod is still alive right
while failing a liveness probe will tell
kubernetes to restart the pod
how does kubernetes probe the containers
the cubelet will do the probing using
the method you configure
with exec action kubernetes will run a
command inside a container
with TCP socket action kubernetes check
if a TCP socket port is open
and with HTTP get action kubernetes
perform nhdp get
here's an exec action you're telling
kubernetes to run a cat command on a
file called healthy in the TMP folder
here's a TCP socket action
you're telling kubernetes to check if
there's an open socket on port 8080
and finally an HTTP get action you're
telling kubernetes to do an HTTP get on
the Health page on Port 8080.
and this concludes this look at
observability
[Music]
in this lab we will set a liveness probe
so let's take a look at our yaml file
we will deploy a pod that we'll call
liveness Dash example is going to be a
PC box
and this is where we're setting the
probe
type is liveness Pro
we're asking to do an exacto so to run a
command inside our container
and the command is cat
and the parameter is that file so under
the TMP folder the file is called
healthy no extension
basically we're asking kubernetes
to run that command if that command is
successful if the file exists well the
probe is successful if the file doesn't
exist the probe will fail okay
uh initial delay seconds we're asking
kubernetes to wait for five seconds
before starting to probe and then period
seconds to five we're asking kubernetes
to probe every five seconds
the last parameter is failure threshold
set to two basically we're telling
kubernetes that the liveness probe will
fail when two probes will fail
now for uh the purpose of this lab we
will set something a little bit funky uh
just so we're able to do this test
we're um we're running a command when
the container starts uh it's dutch and
basically this will create that healthy
file
and then we're telling the container to
wait for 15 seconds
and then to delete that file
right and just a little trick too so
we'll be able to to quickly see the
effect of the lavenous probe
okay
Let's uh deploy our pod
and let's quickly do a cube CTL describe
pod
all right successfully pull the image
the container was created
okay so let's
do that again a few times and we'll see
what happens
just rerun the command out
liveness profile cat can't open okay two
times over five seconds
and now kubernetes is killing the Pod
awesome
and uh
is still killing
so you see that here the the Pod was in
an unhealthy State here
so now it's in the killing mode oh
and then uh kubernetes is pulling again
the BusyBox image and starting a new one
right
and then
it's on LT again
and the process starts uh starts again
all right let's do our cleanup let's
delete our pod and we'll force it
you don't want to wait for it to end
perfect
[Music]
let's take a look at some dashboards
while it's fine to use a terminal to get
a view of your cluster You may wish to
use a graphical user interface instead
luckily there are many options available
we will take a look at these three
popular and free options the kubernetes
dashboard the lens desktop application
and K9s a dashboard that runs in the
terminal
let's start with the kubernetes
dashboard
it's a web UI that you can install as an
add-on inside your cluster
it's not installed by default by Docker
desktop and also by most Cloud providers
the rule of thumb is if you don't need
it don't install it
a because it runs inside the cluster so
you need to find a way to expose it over
the internet
and B well because of that it's a known
Vector of attack
that being said the kubernetes dashboard
that you see the various resources
deployed inside your cluster
simply select the type in the left menu
and you can also edit them by clicking
on the edit icon
and you can edit the yaml file and click
on update to change the Manifest file
lens is a IDE that runs locally on Mac
windows and Linux so you need to install
it on your OS
on top of viewing the resources and
editing the yaml Manifest
you can also use a built-in editor and
also a built-in terminal
lens is maintained by mirantis and you
can download it from this URL
here's the overview dashboard that lets
you see a resource count
like the kubernetes dashboard you can
select a resource click on the edit
button
and it did the Manifest directly in lens
you can also type commands using the
built-in terminal
K9s is a cool text dashboard that runs
in a terminal
and you can install it on Windows Mac
and Linux
it might sound strange to run the
dashboard in a terminal but this makes a
lot of sense Kina NS is super light
starts in an instant and gives you a
clean view of all your resources
you can get the information about the
cluster the resources and you can take a
or make a series of action like deleting
a resource viewing the logs
here we have a list of the pods
currently running in the default
namespace
want to view the services that are
currently running simply type
colon
and type SVC to list the objects type
foreign pressing s while a part is
selected will open a shell
you can also set a port forward by
typing shift f
you can even see the part logs
I really like this K9s dashboard in a
terminal and use it all the time
and this concludes this look at the
kubernetes dashboards
thank you
[Music]
in this lab we'll take a look at Lens so
lens is a free dashboard that you can
install on Windows Mac and Linux here's
the URL
k8s
lenss.dev let's take a look at the
website
from there you can install it it runs on
Mac windows and Linux so you can
download the setup files here
or if you're using a security on Windows
you can use shoko install lens or Brew
on Mac and Brew install cast lens
all right
I've already launched a lens here and by
default it should take you to your
Docker desktop cluster if not or if you
want to select another cluster click on
the hamburger menu to the left and
select add cluster
Lance will look at the cube config file
and you'll be able to select your
clusters from that drop down list so
here I have my demo cluster in the cloud
so I can select that
and click on ADD cluster
I can be connected to multiple clusters
here's my Docker desktop here's my demo
so let me switch back to dockerdist up
here
okay
so first thing first uh let's deploy
something on our cluster
here I have a yaml file
it's a deployment
we'll have three replicas of an image
called Hello app okay nothing fancy here
let's deploy
this all right and let me switch back to
uh lens
here
now let's click here on workloads
and overview
so we should see three parts running
here one deployment and one replica set
I can either from the top menu select
path or from this workload menu select
paths here and the other type of objects
here
so here are my three parts
I have one deployment and one replica
set if I click on an object I get more
information
labels annotations and so on and so on
so
something that you would have at the
terminal at the common line by typing
Cube CTL describe uh replica set or
deployment or pod and the object name
here
but here is presented in a nice UI
all right
let's take a look at our pods here okay
let's see what we can do let's say
we want to delete this one so I can
select it like this and from the Ellis
menu to the right I can open that and
select remove
right or I can remove it
right there
okay let's do that
remove item hello yep
remove it and since it's a deployment uh
kubernetes will create a new One
automatically
pretty cool uh let's uh take a look at
the logs
we can see the logs from there we can
open a shell
so at last
a pretty cool front directly from that
UI if I click on edit
well I can edit the Manifest file
and click on Save and close that will
update that object
let me cancel that
close close this there's a built-in
terminal so by default you have a small
icon here called terminal if you click
on it if you click on this open button
that will open the terminal so I can
type command Cube C Cube CTL get the
pods
right
you can try to delete an object directly
here so let me copy this object name
Cube CTL delete uh
and let's paste that
we should see right right away we see uh
something happening uh at the top of the
screen
all right
uh what's cool is that if you have more
than one cluster you can switch between
these clusters so here let me uh just to
prove it
clear and the
qctl uh get the nodes
okay on Docker desktop I have only one
node let me select My Demo cluster
my terminology open it
there's no deployment yet but let's just
do a cube CTL
get nodes
and for sure I have three nodes in this
in this cluster
that's pretty cool
just by selecting the cluster I can
switch and I have a terminal that is in
the right context
pretty cool
so I just scratched the surface there's
a lot more information that we can get
like a configuration the config Maps the
secrets
what the network services that are
installed here I have a cluster IP
service
storage so the persistent volume claims
persistent volume storage classes so
here in my cluster in the cloud I have
four search classes defined for me the
namespaces and so on and so on all the
information that you would get from the
command line using cubectl you get the
same information but from a nice UI
so once you're done exploring don't
forget to delete your deployment
thank you
[Music]
in this lab we will use K9s a super
great dashboard running inside a
terminal so you can get more information
about the K9s at the website
k9scli.io
here's the website nice logo
and you can look at the documentation
and the how to install K9s from that
website if you're on Windows
you can install it using chocolaty so
Chico install K9s on Mac OS Brew install
K9s and on Linux take a look at the
documentation
all right
Let's uh first deploy something in our
clusters
here in our yaml file I have a simple
deployment with three replicas of a
simple
container or image called Hello app
nothing fancy here
let's deploy that uh right away
okay and let's open a terminal or come
in line comment prom whatever you name
it
and let me type K9s
all right let me stretch that a little
bit
well it's super cool it's a dashboard
running inside the terminal it's super
light and it gives you tons of
functionality so here
I have my deployment so I'm in the
default namespace you can look at my my
deployment I can enter on an object I
get more information type Escape go back
I have information about my cluster uh I
can issue some some commands so Ctrl D I
can delete a a pod let me do that let me
kill that poor part here
uh are you sure yes
see you have feedback visual feedback of
of uh what's happening
the Pod that I deleted was kill was in
the terminating State and the new one
was uh created uh right away
I can yeah it D to describe
the resource escape to uh to go back
Ctrl K to kill I just deleted one but I
can do a Ctrl k
there we go
I can see the log so let's let's switch
to the second one type l
and I can look at the uh the logs
I can open a shell also by typing here
the
S letter doing the less
right you can type exit go back I can uh
even configure a port forward
pretty cool here I can look at the yaml
file also
let me type Escape
here we have the parts that are listed
but if I type Colin I can change that
let's say let me type deploy
so here's my deployment now if I type e
I will edit the deployment and let's
change the number of senses or replicas
from three to four
and let's close that
right and now I have four out of four so
let's uh I'll type Colin again and type
but
here are my four pods
super interesting it's a free tool it's
super light it's super fast and I always
have one open so I can see
visually what's happening uh inside my
cluster when I'm issuing some some
commands
let's go back uh to uh our page here our
Visual Studio code and let's simply
delete our deployment and let me switch
back right away here
and they're gone
pretty cool too
[Music]
let's see how to scale pods
the horizontal pad to scalar is a
kubernetes feature that allows you to
scale the number of Parts up and down
it uses the metric server to gather the
pods utilization
pods app must have requests and limits
defined
the HPA checks the metric server every
30 seconds and scale the number of PODS
according to the minimum and maximum
number of replicas defined
to prevent racing conditions the HPA
Waits some period of time after a
scaling event by default this delay on
scale-up events is 3 minutes and the
delay on scaled down events is 5 minutes
in this part definition you specify the
CPU and memory requests and limits
the request is what's allocated at first
and the limit is what you allow the part
to burst to
in this example the Pod will start with
64 megabyte of ram but can burst up to
128 megabyte if needed
you configure the HPA using a manifest
specifying the deployment you want to
scale
the Min and max number of replicas
and the metric you want the HPA to scale
on in this case we tell the HPA to kick
in when the average CPU utilization is
above 50 percent
here's the cheat sheet for the HPA
commands
so you can create one using the
imperative way using cubectl autoscale
deployment the name and the metric and
replicas number
you can create one using the yaml file
you can get the autoscaler status by
using cubectl get HPA and the HPA name
and of course you can delete the HPA
using the yaml file or cube CTL delete
HPA with its name
foreign
this lecture about scaling pods
[Music]
in this lab we will use the horizontal
particle scalar to scale a pod
for the HP it worked it needs some data
some metrics coming from the metric
server and by default it's not installed
by Docker desktop
just make sure I'll open the terminal
and what we'll do we'll get a list of
the parts running in the cube system
namespace
Accord DNS at CD Cube API server proxy
provisioner no nothing that looks like
metric server okay
to install it you need to run this yaml
file coming from this git repo on
kubernetes-6 special integers group and
Metric server
but
you need to make a small modification to
to it
let's take a look at the components that
yaml file
need to do you need to edit it if you
download it directly from the git repo
and you locate the deployment section
there it is deployment
and what you need to do is add this
parameter
a cubelet dash insecure-tls
if not the metric server will not run on
Docker desktop all right
let's deploy our metric server cubectl
apply Dash F components Dot yaml
awesome
what we can do we can run again Cube
City I'll get pod in the cube system
namespace
aha metrics server there it is it might
take a few a couple of minutes for the
metric server to start running
now that the metric server is running
let's take a look at our deployment
uh it's a deployment and what we'll
deploy is a web server called HPA Dash
example uh listening on Port 80. so it's
a simple web server that will return a
web page nothing fancy
what we'll do uh will also deploy a busy
box and from that busy box will it that
web server uh in a loop and that should
generate some traffic
awesome let's
deploy our
web server
let's get a list of the pods running in
the default namespace awesome it's
running
let's enable our Auto scaler so Cube CTL
Auto scale a deployment called HP Dash
deployment and a metric called CPU
percent
and we want a minimum of one instance
and a maximum of four
okay
let's validate that we have an HPA Cube
CTL get HPA that will list all the hpas
running
on my cluster there's only one awesome
let's now deploy our busy box
and let's connect
or open a session on that busy box
perfect
and here's our endless loop that will uh
it the web server
that should generate some traffic
okay let's take a look at our
K9s
I have my deployment here my HPA
deployment and my busy box
and area we have three instances of our
deployment right now
awesome
so the HPA worked and now what I can do
is start the loop by hitting Ctrl C
and I'll type exit to exit my busy box
and from there I can delete my HPA
but be careful when you do that I'll
delete my HP here if we take a look at
the deployments there's still three
nothing will scale that down since the
HP uh has been deleted
let's delete our busy box
and let's delete our deployment that
should delete all three instances
take a look here yep all three are
terminating
and optionally you can delete the metric
server by using cubectl delete and the
components.yaml file here
[Music]
we are at the end of this Docker
containers and kubernetes fundamental
scores
congratulations you are now an official
kubernetes Ninja
[Applause]
the next steps for you would be to
deploy containers in the cloud using
services from a cloud provider
these courses will teach you how to do
that on Google cloud and Azure and also
on smaller Cloud providers like Linux
and digitalocean
the best part is that each offer free
credit usage when creating new accounts
this way you can create a managed
kubernetes service in the cloud without
breaking the bank
if you enjoyed the course you can help
me by making a small donation this is
the link to my buy me a coffee page
I want to say a big thank you for
learning Docker and kubernetes using my
course and I wish you all the best